Guten Morgen Liebe. Guten Morgen Tim.
Äh ja das neueste Antiiterpaket.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die hundertneunzigste Ausgabe äh prescht mitten in die äh Sommerpause der Meterebene hinein. Eine kleine Ausnahme. Ansonsten lag hier eine Menge Prag brach und äh liegt auch noch ein bisschen brach.
Der August muss ausgelebt werden. Haben wir auch getan,
wenn man auch am Ende der Sendung glaube ich nochmal ein bisschen zusammenfassen, was sich da alles so bisher äh für,
Hacker, Spaß angeboten hat und auch in der Zukunft noch angeboten hat, aber ähm ja, während man eben solche Dinge verfolgt, rollt langsam,
Wahlkampf und andere unangenehm unangenehmen Dinge auf einen zu und äh ja dann muss man auch mal wieder eine Sendung einschieben.
Ja, wie ist er? Wisst ihr der Spruch, wenn die Katze aus dem Hause ist, tanzen die Mäuse auf dem Antiterror-Paket?
Irgendwie sowas, ja.
Guckst du mal im Moment nicht hin.
Sind sie schon wieder alle rausgekrochen.
Aber vielleicht sollten wir erstmal mit ein bisschen Feedback äh geben oder einpflegen. Kam ja dann zur letzten Sendung doch einiges.
Wenn man über so umstrittene Themen diskutiert.
Andere Sichtweisen schnell daher, das ist ja auch okay, das wollen wir ja auch so.
Womit fing's an? Wir hatten viel Pferd, ein viel Terror, für Amok, wie man's auch immer im Einzelnen nennen soll und haben auch den einen oder anderen Rückblick äh beliefert, zum Beispiel in der Frage,
wie darf und soll die Polizei potentielle Gefährder in der Öffentlichkeit äh,
Moment des Geschehens äh stoppen und vor allem, wie darf sie.
Schussgewalt einsetzen. Dort ist da auch auf ein Beispiel verwiesen, nämlich den Vorfall in Berlin vorm Roten Rathaus am Brunnen, wo ja.
Der nackte Mann im Brunnen erschossen wurde.
Ja, da gab's auch eine andere Perspektive drauf. Das war also alles völlig in Ordnung. Ähm.
Aber wichtig ist äh inhaltlich ähm,
Florian kommentiert, hallo liebes muss ich leider korrigieren bei Gefahr für Leib und Leben schießen Polizisten nicht auf die Beine, sondern auf die größte Trefferfläche, also Brust und Bauch. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der Angreifer zugedrönt weiter auf dich zuläuft und,
doch trifft, ist einfach zu groß. Abgesehen davon, dass die Polizisten vielleicht daneben schießen könnten. Ja, macht Sinn. Äh.
Dass sie jetzt nicht irgendwie äh auf ein kleines, feines Ziel schießen und.
Ja, hütet, hütet euch davor auf Polizisten zuzurennen, die schießen nicht auf die Beine.
Vor allem wenn ihr nackt seid und gerade irgendwie einen Brunnen umher läuft mit dem Messer in der Hand. Es gab ja dann auch nochmal einen Link auf dieses Video. Ich hatte das noch nicht äh gesehen. Mir war gar nicht bewusst, dass das so äh öffentlich geworden ist.
Ja, dadurch ist es glaube ich auch öffentlich. Also dadurch, dass es eben dieses Video gab, ähm war das damals ein größeres Thema.
Ja, also da wird dann noch darüber diskutiert, war das jetzt okay, dass der Polizist in den Boden gegangen ist oder nicht und war das okay, dass der geschossen hat, als der Mann mit einem Messer auf ihn zugerannt ist.
Ja klar ist das OK wenn du wenn jemand mit einem Messer auf dich zurennen und du als Polizist einen Schuss verfasst, dass du davon Gebrauch machst
Ich frage mich halt nur, was hat dieser Polizist in diesem Brunnen gemacht, bei dem Mann mit einem Messer? Ja, also das äh hat sich mir ähm nicht erschlossen. Man hätte ja auch aus der,
von außerhalb des Brunnens sagen können, du äh wird jetzt auch kalt, äh lege mal das Messer weg und komme raus. Ne, aber okay.
Das ist ja hier nicht äh Brunnenpolitik oder was auch immer.
Strategie.
Dann haben wir äh einen äh Kommentar äh bekommen
von Puddingpulver. Weiter passt die Aussage von Herrn Neumann Herr Erdogan war schon immer schlimm und irre und wahnsinnig nicht mit meinem Geschichtsverständnis überein. Soweit mir bekannt hat Erdogan nach dem Wahlsieg zweitausendzwei erstmal sehr viel Positives veranlasst
Ähm da muss ich sagen, das verbiete ich mir. Ähm wir haben eine freundliche Kommentarkultur und es gibt kein,
Grund mich da jetzt einfach zu sietzen, ja? Man kann Meinungsverschiedenheiten haben, aber da muss man äh mich hier nicht Herr Neumann. Ja, also das ist.
Oder Michael Brittlaven.
Herr Brittlerfend, ich habe sie auch, äh ja, du würdest auch Herr Prittlaft, also das, nee, so nicht.
Genau das ist das widerspricht auch unserem Selbstverständnis als Berufsjugendliche.
Genau. Also so so nicht. Äh
zu Erdogan äh sehr viel Positives veranlasst. Ja, da ist dann halt die Frage, was man jetzt als positiv veranlasst äh bewertet und was da auch dann wirklich auf Erdogans ähm Kappe geht oder was auch wirtschaftliche Entwicklung waren, die sich einfach so ergeben haben.
Ähm interessant ist ähm.
Das wusste ich auch äh bis dato nicht oder waren wir nicht so geläufig, dass der gute Herr Erdogan mal ein paar Tage im Knast war, nämlich äh vier Monate,
nachdem er äh bei einer Konferenz in siert ähm ein religiöses Gedicht zitiert hat.
Von Zia Gürkal, in dem der äh Satz vorkommt, die Demokratie ist nur der Zug
Auf den wir aufsteigen, bis wir am Ziel sind. Die Moscheen sind unsere Kasernen, die Minarette, unsere Bajonette, die kuppeln, unsere Helme und die Gläubigen unsere Soldaten. Äh da ja da hat er also eine
vor dem Staatssicherheitsgericht wegen Missbrauchs der Grundrechte und Freiheiten gemäß Artikel vierzehn der türkischen Verfassung und nach Artikel dreihundert,
Zwölf Schrägstrich zwei der des damaligen türkischen Strafgesetzbuches. Ähm,
das den Straftatbestand auf Stachelung zur Feindschaft, aufgrund von Klasse, Religion, Religion, Sektor oder regionalen Unterschieden? Insgesamt ein zehn Monate kassiert, von denen hat er äh vier abgesessen.
Und ähm.
Eigentlich hat er auch ein lebenslanges äh Politikverbot äh bekommen. Äh wer weiß, äh was daraus geworden ist. Äh aber ja, das würde ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen.
Ja, er hat sich dann auch in dem Zusammenhang ja auch sehr für äh freie Meinungsäußerungen äh eingesetzt und das war so ein bisschen seine Stoßrichtung. Insofern sind seine heutigen Taten in gewisser Hinsicht eigentlich nur noch lächerlich.
Ja, wobei ich auch, also man muss ja noch da mal schauen, also klar, der der dreht da jetzt gerade völlig frei.
Ähm allerdings glaube ich, wenn es in Deutschland dazu käme, dass ein äh Militärputsch versucht wird.
Und äh dieser äh dann irgendwie nicht stattfindet beziehungsweise äh fehlschlägt, ähm dann würden natürlich auch da äh diejenigen, die an der Macht sind, Maßnahmen ergreifen, um.
Ihre Macht zu stabilisieren gegen.
Gegen die gegen den Angriff. Die Frage ist dann, welche Maßnahmen da ergriffen werden und diese Entlastung von irgendwie so und so viertausend Leuten äh erscheint mir da ein bisschen.
Ja, die verhältnismäßigkeit der aktuellen Maßnahmen ist auf jeden Fall nicht gegeben. Ich denke, das kann man einfach mal so festhalten.
Und es macht ja auch nicht den Eindruck, dass da in irgendeiner Form äh nachgelassen wird, sondern es geht halt auch gegen Journalisten in zunehmenden Maße und allein die Reihenfolge dieser Reaktionen,
spricht auch schon für ein sehr strategisches Vorgehen so nicht als allererstes waren die Richter dran.
Erstmal alle entlassen, die in irgendeiner Form jetzt äh für die kommenden Maßnahmen dort da noch eine eigene Meinung formulieren könnten und dann,
Schritt für Schritt halt auch gegen Aktivisten, gegen die Akademiker, die sich irgendwie nicht äh klar zu seinem äh Weg bekennen, et cetera.
Die Liste ist ja lang, das haben wir ja hier auch alle schon aufgezählt, also wir sehen da ehrlich gesagt wenig Anlass da von unseren Aussagen äh groß abzuweichen.
Schon getätigt haben.
Dann kommentiert äh der oder das äh Pixack ähm.
Es ist nicht so, dass es einen qualitativen Unterschied gibt, der in den Fällen Würzburg und München eine Unterscheidung zwischen Terror und Amok live Love zulässt, sondern nur Hintergrund, Herkunft, Ideologie
Hautfarbe et cetera des Täters. Äh weißer Nazi, gleich Amoklauf,
Äh Geflüchteter, nicht weißer, gleich Terror. Ähm.
Man kann ohne den Hintergrund des Täters zu kennen, bereits durch eines dieser Schlagworte. In einer der Überschriften darauf schließen und die folgende Diskussion absehen. Zur Diskussion sagt er äh bei.
Äh Terror und dem nicht weißigen Täter ist dann die Rede von mehr Überwachung äh und ähm.
Der weiße Täter mit dem Amoklauf, äh da ist dann der Fokus auf irgendwie Killerspiele. Ja, es gab ja nur so äh es flammte da auch kurz diese Killerspieldebatte auf. Äh die habe ich aber dann irgendwie bewusst ausgeblendet, weil die irgendwie auch ein bisschen sowas von kalter Kaffee ist.
Ähm aber das ist, denke ich, auch hier sehr,
sehr gut beobachtet und äh deswegen kritisiert Pixack. Ich finde es etwas schade, dass ihr das Bullshit Wording so unkritisch übernehmt und insofern sei das hier nochmal. Äh darauf sei hier nochmal darauf aufmerksam gemacht.
Ähm AD äh hat äh wie immer äh ausführlich kommentiert oder kommentiert sehr häufig. Ähm,
Und hat mal diese Millionenschäden durch äh durch den Cyber äh in in ein wichtiges,
rechtes Licht gerückt, nämlich während da irgendwie von vierzig Millionen im Jahr die Rede ist, haben wir äh nach äh Schaden, die Rede ist, haben wir eine halbe Milliarde
jedes Jahr schaden äh durch Wohnungseinbrüche, was äh denke ich dann schon mal eine eine qualitative.
Oder eine quantitative Einordnung der Phänomene hier ermöglicht, finde fand ich auch ein äh sehr guten Hinweis, den ich tatsächlich auch schon äh an anderer Stelle sofort dann äh fleißig zitiert habe. Ähm.
Und dann gab's doch die, gab's ja diese Debatten äh um äh warum hat jetzt äh ähm.
Elgor die Wahl verloren. Ich habe ja gesagt, na ja, dadurch, dass ich ein weiterer linker Kandidat damals aufgestellt hat
war der Ralf Ralf Nader, dass der den Gor natürlich Stimmen gekostet hat und den Busch nicht. Und dann war jetzt die war natürlich da der Punkt, so ja ähm
Wäre Florida neu ausgezählt worden, hätte Elgor gewonnen. Das ist ja quasi inzwischen bekannt, ne? Das ist eigentlich nicht,
nicht mit so richtig rechten Dingen zuging bei der ersten Wahl äh von George Bush. Ähm.
Und dann haben wir da so ein bisschen rumdiskutiert, ja, Vergoa ein besserer Kandidat gewesen, habe ich da gesagt, hätte ihn nicht die hätte Florida eben nicht die Wahl gekostet. Da gibt's dann irgendwie oder ich weiß gar nicht, wer das jetzt gesagt hat, ich gucke da gerade nur drauf. Ähm,
Interessant fand ich da, dass dann auch im weiteren Verlauf so der äh der Punkt gebracht wurde, ja
Was ist das für ein Wahl beziehungsweise Demokratieverständnis, wenn man sagt, man solle strategisch wählen, ja? Und sagt also quasi,
kein ähm.
Linken Gegenkandidaten oder keinen zweiten linken Kandidaten aufstellen, weil der nur den Linken was kostet und dann am Ende dann der Rechte gewinnt. Jetzt mal als Beispiel äh zwischen äh Trump und Clinton ähm.
Das klassische Red Shake Greencheck äh Problem.
Ja, aber es ist halt eine Präsidentschaftswahl, die du wählst halt nur einen Präsidenten und da musst du natürlich diese äh diese,
ähm diese.
Dir darüber Gedanken machen, dass du jetzt also kein du weißt, es wird äh solange also wenn die Republikaner jetzt nicht den Trump doch nochmal absägen, weil sie sehen Scheiße, der,
der kriegt ja die Mission Lounge Code so und dann sind wir alle haben wir auch nichts von. Ähm äh wird es halt entweder sein, dass er die Wahl gewinnt oder Hillary Clinton und ein dritter Kandidat als Außenseiter wird diese Wahl einfach nicht gewinnen,
Das heißt, du kannst da äh es ist,
es gibt eben nur einen. Es ist was anderes, wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein paar in ein Parlament wählst äh und dir dann Leute davon abraten, was weiß ich, die kleine Splitterpartei nicht zu wählen, weil die unter Umständen an der Fünf-Prozent-Hürde scheitert. Dann ist das natürlich ein,
da greift ja dieses Argument, da sollte es natürlich nicht strategisch äh oder der sollte es, ist es,
Ein schlechtes Phänomen, wenn dann laut strategisch gewählt wird, aber bei einer Präsidentschafts äh Rolle gibt's halt nur einen. Die werden halt nicht nach Mehrheitsverhältnissen äh ins Weiße Haus gesetzt.
Ja, das Problem ist,
Das Wahlverfahren ist an der Stelle das Problem. So, weil das Leute halt überhaupt in so eine Situation gezwungen werden, strategisch äh äh wählen zu.
Also das zu erwägen,
auf Basis einer strategischen Entscheidung, die ja auch nur eine Wahrnehmung von Umfragen ist, letzten Endes, also auch gar keine konkret greifbare, nachweisbare äh Realität darstellt, wird halt einfach das Beifahrer äh das Falschverhalten von vornherein,
verfälscht, ver.
Ändert ähm und es ist halt nicht mehr der eigentliche freie Wille und das Problem lässt sich eigentlich relativ leicht lösen, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum das.
Du meinst diese Wahl, wo man dann einfach sagt, äh nennen sie alle Namen, mit denen sie äh einverstanden werden.
Genau, also das genau, sogenannte Provel Voting, was ja auch beim CC-Vorstandswahlen zum Beispiel äh zum Einsatz kommt, zu kreuz halt einfach alle an, die für dich okay sind.
Und dann kannst du halt deine ganzen Nebenkandidaten auch wählen und sagst halt aber ja meinetwegen auch Clinton so.
Und dann dann hast du eben den anderen auch die Stimme äh gegeben und dann kriegen die quasi auch die, die tatsächliche natürliche Zustimmung,
mal auch wirklich auf den Tisch und kannst auch dadurch relativ klar ablesen, wie viele Leute stehen jetzt wirklich.
Hinter einem Kandidaten, ne? Und du vergibst halt nichts. Also das ist.
Gibt ja überhaupt haben wir auch schon glaube ich ein paar Mal hier angesprochen, aber können wir ja auch nochmal sagen. Also ich denke, dass.
In der Wahlforschung genug passiert ist in den letzten Dekaden, dass man schon das ein oder andere Wahlsystem schon mal auch überlegen soll. Es gab ja ähnliche Vorfälle
Frankreich mit der Präsidentenwahl genau diese Konstellation auch zersplittertes linkes Lager, wo alle der Meinung waren, Jospa wäre eigentlich sozusagen der nächste Präsident.
Was er dann aber nicht wurde, weil eben andere linke Kandidaten waren, die sich dann eben schön die Stimmen geteilt haben mit dem Ergebnis, dass am Ende
alle dann doch für den verhassten Schirak gestimmt haben, damit's halt nicht lepen wird. Ähnliche Konstellation jetzt auch wieder in Österreich mit der Präsidentenwahl und
das sind alles so Probleme, die man eben mit Provel Voting einfach komplett wegkriegt und dann braucht man halt auch keine Stichwahl.
Ja, also so hoffen wir, dass die Amerikaner das hören und äh.
Sprechende Maßnahmen einleiten.
Wir werden nächstes Jahr evaluieren, wie weit das Projekt ist. Äh dann gab's noch haben wir noch äh über diese dieses Snowden Device da gesprochen ähm.
Wo auch von AD glaube ich der äh Hinweis kam wenn man Journalismus in einem Gefahrengebiet betreibt, ist das Mobiltelefon zu Hause lassen keine Option, ja? Ähm es ist zur Koordinierung unverzichtbar,
da es neben dem Mobilfunk oft keine andere Kommunikationsinfrastruktur gibt. Ähm, okay, groundet, dann gehen die Journalisten jetzt von mir aus mit ihrem Telefon dahin,
gehen die Tracking-Gefahr ein, aber dann sollen sie doch bitte äh dieses Telefon einfach in einen anderen Raum legen oder äh in den in den Karton oder in die äh in die,
Mikrowelle oder in den Kühlschrank oder was auch immer ähm,
und nicht dass das Mikrofon und die ganzen Sensoren auf den Tisch legen,
während sie sprechen und Tim macht jetzt hier gerade die die schöne Keriophone Axon von Aram Barthol. Also dieses Säckchen nähen. Ähm auf dem Bildschirm,
Das kann man auch machen, aber auch dann kann das Telefon immer noch ähm aufzeichnen. Also Licht ist einfach nicht in den Raum, dann habt ihr halt eine Sorge weniger.
Ähm von der euch dieses Snowden Device eben nicht befreien kann,
Äh dann haben wir Eier, dieser Milo, ja, äh der hat M kommentiert. Ich hoffe, das war nicht. Milow Himself.
War aber freundlich und sagt ähm.
Nur weil sein Gehate und Getrolle nicht legitim oder lustig ist, muss man ihn nicht bannen. Twitter ist gerade dafür gemacht, nicht wie bei YouTube oder Facebook jeden Scheiß zu löschen. Äh wenn einem persönlich etwas nicht gefeilt, kann man die Person
Blocken und hat.
Ich glaub der Satz ist kaputt aber man kann die Leute blocken und sie behalten aber eben die Möglichkeit sich dazu äußern. Das ist eine Ansicht die ich
prinzipiell teile und wenn das äh ich,
wenn der Eindruck erstand entstanden ist, dass ich das jetzt besonders toll finde, dass dieser Account gelöscht wurde ähm dann möchte ich das revidieren oder äh klarstellen. Ich ähm finde das eigentlich immer ähm.
Entlarvend genug, wenn Leute sich in dieser Form äußern und du hattest ja auch in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, dass er eigentlich dieses Löschen als seinen größten
Erfolg.
Sieg ansieht, der ja.
Seinen größten Sieg ansieht. Ähm.
Da kann man dann aber auch nichts gegen machen. Tatsache ist, dass er einfach ja
schlicht gegen die äh die Regeln, die Twitter halt einfach aufgestellt hat für das soziale Verhalten in diesem Netzwerk äh massiv verletzt hat und nicht das erste Mal und das dann letzten Endes eben die Konsequenz ist. Denn Blocken und so weiter
Klar, meinetwegen, äh, aus den Augen aus dem Sinn ändert nichts daran, dass diese Person dann halt immer noch herscharen von äh zweiten, dritten und vierten äh An,
die dann halt über alle möglichen anderen Kanäle auch noch auf diese Personen einschlagen, das haben wir bei Gamer Gate schon gesehen bis hin zu vollautomatisierten Hating mit Bots und automatisch erstellten Accounts et cetera. Das ist ja alles äh nichts Neues und.
Also ich habe da relativ wenig Probleme mit.
Das ähm,
der entscheidende Punkt, den ich da eigentlich auch machen wollte ist, dass sich jetzt dieser Typ, ja, den kannst du jetzt nicht, also das kannst du machen, aber es du kriegst halt du kriegst halt keinen Applaus dafür, wenn du ausgerechnet aus der Nummer,
Jetzt irgendwie da so 'n Vorwurf gegen Twitter erhebst, wie irgendwie Hassange und sagst hier Cyber Fordalismus, wir machen jetzt unser eigenes Twitter, äh, Wiki Twitter oder so was, ne?
Geht übrigens auch hier für die ähm.
Für die gute Frau Künast, natürlich ist das eine Frage, die man stellen muss. Wieso hat die Polizei diesen Menschen da erschossen? Wie ist es dazu gekommen? Ich möchte diese Informationen haben. Aber du musst eben überlegen, ob das jetzt gerade etwas ist, was.
Was du politisch versuchst auszuschlachten,
daraus Gewinn zu ziehen oder Ressourcen zu ziehen, das klappt eben nicht, also dich mit so einem mit so einem Rassistentroll da irgendwie den jetzt als Speerspitze der Meinungsfreiheit zu positionieren, kannst du machen
Darf sich nun nicht wundern, wenn dann eben relativ wenig von deinen Äußerungen jetzt in der breiteren Masse verfängt. Da gibt's äh
andere wichtige Beispiele von Meinungsfreiheit, die unterdrückt wird ähm und es wäre ja wirklich äh bedauerlich, wenn wir jetzt ausgerechnet nur noch irgendwelche äh Rassistentrolle
als von der Meinungsfreiheit von der eingeschränkten Meinungsfreiheit bedroht wahrnehmen. Ja, da gibt's also
viele andere Dinge, die äh wo Meinungsfreiheit in Gefahr ist und da eine Meinungsfreiheit in Gefahr ist, die auch ähm.
Sage ich mal, für die, für die Gesellschaft und das Zusammenleben äh sehr viel äh mehr bringt.
Ja, das ist auch so eine, so eine extrem irreführende Debatte, die da immer gerne wieder ins Feld geworfen wird, so dass irgendwie dieses ganze Hating dann einfach als Meinungsfreiheit angesehen wird, ja? Das hat einfach mit Meinungsfreiheit nichts zu tun, wenn man einfach gegen andere Leute da mehr oder weniger operativ vorgeht
und äh da solche Bobs organisiert oder es zumindest zulässt und das einfach nicht in Ordnung.
So, dann äh aber auch ein wichtiger Punkt äh von äh Flying Toaster, da auch der Bann von Milo, Jano Polus in dieser Folge ein Thema war. Zeigt sich eine weitere Gefahr großer Plattformen. Ja, das stimmt natürlich da
habe ich ja dann auch, glaube ich, bei der letzten Sendung,
auch ein bisschen was zugesagt äh zu den großen Plattformen, in die wir als Podcaster nicht gehen sollten. Da gab's dann auch nochmal einen Artikel auf Netzpolitik Org, wo so ein äh auch so ein bisschen.
Halt mal andere Podcaster dazu befragt wurden. Ähm.
Äh kann man auf jeden Fall äh mal lesen für diejenigen, die diese äh Debatte,
interessant finden. Also es gab einige, die sagen, das ist alles irgendwie viel zu äh.
Also den Teufel nicht an die Wand malen, andere haben gesagt, ja äh nee, es ist halt eine Debatte, ne? Kann man, habe ich eine Position drin vertreten und gibt es auch andere.
Ähm dann letzter Kommentar, den ich noch hier reinbringen wollte, den fand ich einfach zu schön. Ähm.
Der Münchner Balkonschreier. Also es hat sich, ich habe das dann nachher ich mir war ja nicht ganz klar, ob derjenige, der da äh den.
Kommentar in diesem Video.
Den Kommentar in diesem Video, das war nicht derjenige, der gefilmt hat, sondern der war irgendwie im Balkon da drüber oder da drunter. Gefilmt hatte ein ähm.
Ein anderer Mann, ich glaub ein äh der hat ja auch dann irgendwie kurz Türkisch gesprochen mit seiner Frau oder so. Ähm.
Der Mann äh hat jetzt eine Anzeige bekommen
weil er ja diesen äh Täter da beleidigt hat. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das äh ernst gemeint ist oder äh wer diese Anzeige erstattet hat. Aber das fand ich äh ganz amüsant, äh dass äh dass er dafür jetzt eine, dass er da jetzt einen, dass er jetzt eine
eine Anzeige eingegangen ist und dann muss die Staatsanwaltschaft ja ermitteln und da gibt's halt dieses Video. Und wenn er jetzt, wenn er jetzt Glück hat, äh äh oder Pech hat, wird er halt äh eventuell der
beleidigt, weil er den armen Mann beschimpft hat, der da mit der Knarre rumgerannt ist und Leute ja, manchmal.
Ich weiß, dass äh ich habe ja auch in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, ich äh bin da manchmal ein bisschen.
Äh zynisch in in diesen diesen Themenbereichen? Kommen wir zu dem zu dem äh zum zu,
Zu weiteren Gründen für Zinismus.
Backkampf.
Es ist Wahlkampf und äh das letzte Antiterrorpaket ist ja äh das wird ja langsam,
kalt, also die Tinte trocknet, hat glaube ich irgendwie Tagesschau geschrieben oder so hatte ich das gelesen. Die Tinte trocknet und da muss natürlich jetzt etwas geschehen. Äh das heißt, wir brauchen ein weiteres Antiterror-Paket und da hat jetzt unser
äh Innenminister de Maizire.
Einen Plan zur Erhöhung der Sicherheit in Deutschland vorgestellt, weil wir ja ähm.
So unsicher leben und auch so lange nichts mehr äh getan haben, um äh Sicherheit wieder herzustellen. Das waren ja unhaltbare Zustände.
Und dieses Mal hat er jetzt so eine Liste, also das das tatsächliche Antiterror-Paket ist noch nicht formuliert.
Das soll aber, glaube ich, Ende dieser Woche dann fertig sein.
Aber er hat jetzt also seine äh seine Liste schon mal so seine Ideen schon einmal gesammelt und sagt, also das Internet darf natürlich kein Schutzraum äh für Kriminelle sein und deswegen freut er sich ja auf ähm die,
Ähm über die wir ja auch schon gesprochen haben, wo sie irgendwie vierhundert Beschäftigte haben wollen, um äh Verschlüsselungen zu brechen.
Und er möchte natürlich die Videoüberwachung ausweiten, ja? Muss, es muss mehr,
über Videoüberwachung geben, damit man dann nachher Videos von den Tätern hat, die dann da durchgedreht sind und von der Polizei erschossen wurden, das wird die sicherlich abschrecken. Wenn es dann Videos gibt.
Ähm dann möchte er ähm und das ist glaube ich ein größerer Punkt ähm für.
Telekommunikationsanbieter und Betreiber von.
Telemediendiensten sowie overn the top Services wie WhatsApp oder Skype äh die gleichen Regeln und Pflichten einführen wie für ähm.
Wie für Telekommunikationsanbieter, ja? Also es gibt ja das Telekommunikationsgesetz.
In dem dann eben auch so Sachen äh definiert sind, wie
Man muss abhören können, ähm es muss eine Sicherheit geben, dass das Ding funktioniert und so weiter. Da gibt's relativ viele Regeln für so einen Telekommunikationsanbieter und äh,
Für Skype und WhatsApp und was weiß ich,
Signal Threema und was es da nicht alles gibt, die möchten sie ganz gerne auch unter diese Regeln fassen.
Hatten wir ja auch schon mal im Prinzip die ähnliche Initiative, damals kam sie noch aus äh England von David Camerun, der sich ja groß darüber aufregte, dass er äh nicht sein äh.
Was nicht sein darf und das äh man deswegen alle Messenger und äh Anbieter von Diensten wie Apple wie Google et cetera dazu zwingen soll, doch all ihre ganzen ähm entweder verschlüsselten Kommunika
offen zu legen. Im Prinzip wird jetzt dieselbe Debatte hier wieder aufgemacht und das, obwohl wir ja, glaube ich, vor noch gar nicht so langer Zeit hier äh berichtet haben, dass da gab's auch dieses,
Treffen bei
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium dem beschlossen wurde, dass das ja überhaupt nicht die Linie der Bundesregierung sei und dass ja Sicherheit irgendwie äh wichtig sei für die Wirtschaft und Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung nicht angetoucht wird,
ich sehe das hier nicht so richtig in Leinen mit diesen Kommentaren und äh glaube, dass hier wieder viel Dampfplauderei betrieben wird.
Na der spannende Punkt dabei ist
Also ich habe wir haben den Unterschied hier öfter schon mal äh besprochen, gerade auch als es um das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz ging, habe ich da äh glaube ich relativ viel äh drüber gesprochen, denn diese anderen Dienste, für die gibt es ja auch ein Gesetz.
Und das ist das Telemediengesetz,
Und mit im Zuge des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes wurden, was wurden sowas bestimmte Möglichkeiten angeht schon die ähm Telemediendienste auf eine ähnliche.
Ebene wie Telekommunikationsdienste gebracht. Ähm um auch also mit IT-Sicherheit hatte das eigentlich relativ wenig zu tun, aber.
Ähm es gab eben von den Telekommunikationsanbietern.
Eben die die Klage, dass die sagten, hier wir haben hier wir unterhalten hier zum Beispiel so ein so ein SMS-Dienst und so einen Telefoniedienst und haben da irgendwie fürchterliche Auflagen für
Und äh wenn man das Ganze über Voice over IP macht, kann uns da jeder Konkurrenz machen ähm und hat im Prinzip überhaupt gar keine äh Regulation dazu
Aber worum es hier in Wirklichkeit geht, ist.
Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Denn WhatsApp und Facebook und so weiter, Telemediendienste fallen nicht unter die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Weil die Vorzeitenspeicherung eben äh an den Telekommunikationsanbietern verankert ist.
Und das wird natürlich eine spannende äh Debatte.
Wird ein bisschen schwierig, bei Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh einzuführen. Ich meine, sie können natürlich die verschlüsselten Nachrichten irgendwie gerne zwischenspeichern.
Na ja wäre ja schon mal etwas äh.
Über die über die Verschlüsselung müssen wir gleich nochmal reden, aber ähm dass sie halt sagen wollen, ne, wir wollen für so und so viele Monate wissen, wer wann wohne, äh hier so eine WhatsApp geschickt hat und zwar an wen? Äh das weiß WhatsApp, ja. Das wissen diese Dienste.
Die ruhten ja die Nachrichten, also wissen die und äh vor allem hast du da ja eine Registrierung auf deine Telefonnummer?
Und äh die fallen halt im Moment äh nicht unter die Vorortseinspeicherung und das kann ja nicht sein.
Das kann ja nicht sein, dass da äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht greift und deswegen werden wir das jetzt halt äh wohl relativ bald,
bekommen, dass wir die Vorortsdatenspeicherung im Telemedienteil nochmal bekommen. Das wird weitreichende Konsequenzen haben.
Ja, das ist wirklich eine interessante Debatte, ne, inwiefern diese ganzen Ende zu Ende verschlüsselnden Messenger auch äh tatsächlich eine Transparenz beim Empfänger, Senderempfängerschema herstellen können oder nicht herstellen können auf Basis ihrer Technologie.
Nein, äh das können die also die.
Also WhatsApp und Signal ja zum Beispiel geben dir ja als äh als dein Unique ID einfach die Telefonnummer. Und das ist auch quasi dein interne,
dein dein interner Identifier bei denen und die wissen natürlich äh mit wem du mit welcher anderen, mit welcher anderen Person du da äh kommuniziert hast und die hat auch wieder eine Telefonnummer und das lässt sich ähm äh.
Eigentlich sehr angenehm in das Daten Abfrageschema, Datenmodell äh der Vorortseitenspeicherung.
Das stimmt.
Integrieren. Anders ist das dann zum Beispiel bei ähm Messengern, die nicht diese Telefonnummer haben.
Zum Beispiel.
Genau drei äh Threamer sind sechs Buchstaben glaube ich sechs Buchstaben zahlen. Da ist dann quasi ein.
Dein Public,
deine Identitän. Und da kannst du erstmal prinzipiell einen Account machen, wo Streamer nicht weiß, wer du bist. Die sehen von dir eine IP-Adresse, die sehen, dass du dich dahin verbindest und diese Nachrichten verschickst,
es sind acht, ja. Ähm ja sechs wäre ein bisschen wenig ähm,
um für um die um alle Leute mit einem mit einer zu versorgen. Ähm.
Aber genau, Threema weiß im Zweifelsfall nicht,
die Telefonnummer, es sei denn, die haben auch wieder, ihr weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber vielleicht irgendwo einen Laden mal dein Adressbuch hoch und verknüpfe mit dem Kontakt oder so. Aber die haben äh diese diesen Adentify nicht. Aber weiter im,
im Text Videoüberwachung wollen wir natürlich aber es reicht ja nicht die Videoüberwachung muss intelligent sein, also smart
Smart City und soll dann direkt mal bitte äh mit Gesichtserkennung arbeiten, weil wir haben jetzt diese ganze Biometrie und so. Wir wollen dann irgendwann mal Menschen.
An ihrem Gesicht genauso gut erkennen ähm,
wie an ihrem Fingerabdruck und wenn wir dann erstmal das ganze Land voll hängen haben mit Kameras, dann können wir äh über Gesichtserkennung äh Fahndungen machen. Da können wir wieder ein paar Planstellen bei der Polizei einsparen
weil wir überall äh Kameras hängen haben zu unserer Fahndung.
Ja hier in der Berliner Wahl, die ja jetzt auch ansteht wird ja auch die CDU explizit, damit das ja Videotechnik nur mit der CDU ginge.
Da gibt's so ein Plakat mit Herrn Henkel. Videotechnik äh CDU und jetzt fragen sich halt alle, was er denn damit damit meint, ob da jetzt irgendwie vier K oder HDM hier,
Ja
Na das ist ein sehr, also das ist, denke ich mal, ein schönes ähm.
Ja, also sowas für Veranstaltungs äh Gebäude und so weiter, ist vielleicht interessant, CDU zu wählen. Weil sie mit der Videotechnik nicht so hinkriegen, einfach die CDU fragen.
Ja, das, da wird sich das Neusprechblock noch drum kümmern oder schon äh drum gekümmert haben, denke ich mal.
Oh G.
Mal kurz schauen, neu sprechen.
Ja, Gesichtserkennung, was wessen Gesichter wollen sie denn da wo äh erkennen?
Also Idee die Idee ist.
Ähm jemand wird zur Fahndung ausgeschrieben, dann hast du ja schon ein.
Wenn er einen Pass hat oder so oder einen Personalausweis hast du ja biometrische Daten von dem.
Und dann äh fütterst du einfach nur in deine, in deine Videosystem, in deine allumfassenden Videosysteme äh ein und sagst hier Pridlov finden.
Der ist britischer Flüchtling, der hat die Einwirrungstest nicht bestanden. Äh dem müssen wir äh abschieben, ne?
Ticket bei Air Berlin ist gebucht, Abschiebungsflug für den Pritler und dann gehst du hier vor die Tür und auf der äh darf an den Straßennamen hier im Radio sagen.
Muss schon Datensparsam vorgehen.
Genau, also du gehst hier vor die Tür irgendwo in Berlin aus dem aus dem äh Meterebene äh Geheimbunker und äh dann ist da irgendwie so eine Kamera und dann äh kommt kommt,
Polizeiroboter und äh nimmt dich Gefangen.
Interessanter ist natürlich, ob man äh solche biometrischen Anfragen halt auch an äh Facebook zum Beispiel stellen äh kann.
Haben die das nicht eh schon seit Jahren diese Gesichtserkennung.
Die haben alles drin, also ich denke nicht, dass es jetzt ein schwerwiegendes technisches Problem darstellt, sondern eher ein, wer arbeitet, auf welcher Basis, mit wem, äh, wie zusammen
Problem so, aber es ist natürlich klar, in in dem Moment, wo halt biometrische Datensilos existieren, wenn die Begehrlichkeiten danach halt natürlich größer
es ist jetzt sicherlich nicht sehr schwierig sich politischen Forderungskatalog von irgendeiner,
Partei vorzustellen, wo dann eben auch solche Forderungen gestellt werden, so nach dem Motto ja, hier, wir haben ja ein Suchbefehl, ja? Diese Person wird gesucht,
vielleicht ist ja auf irgendeinem Foto was in eurem Archiv existiert diese Person,
zu sehen und liefert entsprechend weitere Meterdaten über Aufenthaltsorte et cetera.
Wieder so eine Idee ausgegoren, die die Politik noch gar nicht hatte.
Die sich jetzt so die Hände reiten und denkt so, ah mh.
Die Prittlersche Facebookfahndung.
Man darf ja sowieso über diese ganzen Themen eigentlich gar nicht reden, weil man immer das Gefühl hat, man bringt die Leute nur um.
Nur auf kluge Idee der Idee.
Aber die kommen dann leider irgendwann sowieso, von daher ist es äh ja, wahrscheinlich unvermeidlich.
Und dann haben sie noch irgendwie äh sehr schön Sicherheitsüberprüfungen von Personen ähm.
Die aufgrund von sogenanntem Resement oder humanitärer Aufnahme aufgenommen werden. Die möchte er gerne
verschärfen und sagte dazu, wenn ihr nach Deutschland kommen wollt, dann müssen wir eure Sicherheit überprüfen
Und wenn wir eure Sicherheit überprüfen, dann bitten wir euch eure Facebook Kontakte der letzten Monate.
Zu zeigen, die ja im Prinzip auch öffentlich sind,
Das finde ich nicht zu viel verlangt. Weiter, dass man ihren Namen verlangt und dann in öffentlichen Facebook-Chats guckt, ob es Probleme und Hinweise gibt. Da sehe ich so gut wie keine Grundrechtsrelevanz.
Sag mal was hast du so getwittert? Tja also.
Was man getwittert hat, das muss man nicht selber zeigen, das wenn's öffentlich ist, dann können sie es ja auch selber anschauen, dann ist man im Zweifelsfall auch selber schuld. So, aber äh aus den USA kennt man ja das auch schon mit, gib mal Passwort her. Wir gucken mal selber in den Account.
Ich hoffe, dass es hier nicht gemeint.
Habe ich so jetzt noch nicht verstanden, aber ich kann mir das auch sehr gut.
Vorstellen. Und dann natürlich der allgemeine IT-Einsatz muss ausgebaut und optimiert werden, automatisierte Abrufverfahren will er hierzulande und europaweit.
Stärker nutzen äh das polizeiliche Informationswesen muss harmonisiert werden, damit Daten übergreifend analysiert und ausgewertet werden können
alle deutschen
Sicherheitsbehörden sollen Zugang auf das geplante Reiseregister der EU erhalten äh um so die ganzen zersplitterten Datensysteme
Ähm zu konsolidieren, dann hat man also ein eine Datenbank to Rule thema,
Was ich sehr interessant finde, ist.
Ich hatte mich beschlich so das Gefühl, dass ich dachte, ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, wie viele Sicherheitsgesetze
und Verschärfung und Antiterrorpaket und Otto-Katalog und so weiter es überhaupt alles gibt. Und da gibt es auf Tagesschau DE eine
Eine schöne Zusammenfassung der ein, eine kleine Geschichte der Sicherheitsgesetze.
Seit zweitausendeins wohlgemerkt, also.
Seit äh den, dem Anschlägen von New York und Washington. Ähm da gab's zweitausendeins das Sicherheitspaket,
eins äh von Otto Schili ähm wo es dann mit äh wo es hauptsächlich darum ging,
dass die Mitgliedschaft oder Unterstützung einer ausländischen terroristischen Vereinigung unter Strafe gestellt wurde und,
Das Religionsprivileg eingeschränkt wurde, weil man eben gesagt hat, hier sind diese Religionsgemeinschaften und so weiter äh werden
werden wir kontrollieren, beobachten und so weiter
zweitausendzwei musste wollte er dann nachlegen da durfte dann der Verfassungsschutz Informationen bei Telekommunikationsunternehmen Banken und der Post einholen und die Personendaten wesentlich länger als
Vorher speichern das Bundeskriminalamt hat mehr Befugnisse bei der Informationsbeschaffung bekommen. Ähm,
dieses Sicherheitspaket zwei war äh zeitlich befristet, wurde aber dann natürlich äh schön verlängert, also ursprünglich sollte es nur bis äh zweitausendsechs gehen, dann wurde es verlängert äh und zweitausendelf wurde es,
verlängert bis zweitausendfünfzehn.
Dann noch zweitausendzwei äh das Sicherheitspaket für Sicherheitspaket zwei war grade durch, dann kam die Rasterfahndung.
Wieder, denn die äh die wurde also die wurde nachher auch nochmal von irgendwelchen Richtern kassiert, aber es war bei den meisten so. Ähm,
Rasterfahrung gab's ja ursprünglich schon mal in den, ich glaube das war so raff, ne? Siebziger Jahre.
Ja, ja, das, das war so der Anfang der achtziger Jahre kam das dann halt alles auf, das war ja dann sauer auch der frühe Auseinandersetzung mit äh des CCs, mit dem mit dem Start.
Zweitausenddrei äh wurde das Antiterror-Strafrecht äh verschärft. Also die Strafhöhen wurden äh heraufgesetzt. Zweitausendvier das Terrorismusabwehrzentrum,
indem die Sicherheitsbehörden der Länder und des Bundes äh besser ihre Arbeit koordinieren sollen,
Ziel hier die Bekämpfung des radikalen Islamismus.
Eigentlich immer. Ähm das es steht auch relativ viele Kritik, weil eben Landespolizei, Bundespolizei und Geheimdienste dort zusammensitzen und wir ja hier auch schon öfter betont haben, dass es da ein Trennungsgebot gibt aus äh historischen Gründen.
Noch im Jahre zweitausendvier äh gab's ein neues Zuwanderungsgesetz ähm
wo dann Justiz und Exekutive eine klare Handgaband habe gegen Terrorverdächtige äh Ausländer hatten ähm,
und leicht diese leichte ähm ausweisen konnten, ebenso wie geistige Brandstifter.
Zweitausendfünf das Luftsicherheitsgesetz, das äh wird auch noch häufig äh diskutiert. Da ging es darum, dass man gesagt hat, okay, was ist denn, wenn jetzt irgendwie so ähm ein Passagier äh
Flugzeug entführt wird und,
zufliegt oder man weiß, dass dieses äh Flugzeug entführt wurde, um es,
zu einer Bombe zu machen, ne? Also wie halt in in New York geschehen, dass man dann sagt, okay, ähm wir erlauben der Bundeswehr dieses.
Flugzeug abzuschießen, um.
Um diesen Anschlag zu verhindern. Ähm, das wurde aber direkt ein Jahr später einkassiert vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, weil sie sagen es verstößt gegen die Menschenwürde.
Äh und weil der Einsatz der Streitkräfte mit militärischen Waffen im Inland von der Verfassung nicht erlaubt ist, ne? Also du hättest ja im Prinzip eine Situation, wo unter Umständen die Bundeswehr im deutschen Luftraum.
Deutsche Bürger tötet,
Da gibt's auch dieses dieses Theaterstück da von Ferdinand von Schirach, Terror, ähm was genau dieses Luftsicherheitsgesetz so ein bisschen äh behandelt oder diesen ähm.
Dieses moralische oder ethische Dilemma, ne, mit dem töte ich jetzt hier oder nicht und wie auch immer, ne. Das war
zweitausendvier und wir sind immer noch äh zweitausendfünf, wir sind immer noch, es kommt noch einiges. Der biometrische Reisepasskampf zweitausendfünf. Zweitausendsechs kam die Antiterrordatei, wo dann Polizei und Geheimdienste eine gemeinsame Datenbank bekommen haben
auf die insgesamt bundesweit achtunddreißig Sicherheitsbehörden
zugreifen und und Daten einfüttern. Zweitausendsechs auch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung erster Versuch ähm die dann zweitausendzehn von den Verfassungs äh Richtern
gekippt wurde und dann jetzt zweitausendvierzehn,
dann auch eben auf dem EuGH vom EuGH gekippt wurde und deswegen zweitausendfünfzehn neu beschlossen werden musste wie wir uns alle erinnern,
zweitausendacht kam dann das BKA-Gesetz.
Wo dem Bundeskriminalamt der Tätigkeitsbereich der Gefahrenabwehr ausgeweitet,
wurde. Ähm allerdings eben nur im Bereich internationaler Terrorismus, da dann auch die Online äh Durchsuchung, da hatten wir ja ähm vor einigen Monaten die,
Folge mit Konstanze kurz bei uns zu Gast, wo es dann noch um die äh um diese ganzen BKA-Gesetzsachen ging. Ähm.
Zweitausendneun gab's dann eine Strafe für Terrorausbildung, also wer ein Terrorcamp besucht äh,
macht sich damit strafbar in Deutschland. Ähm zweitausendelf dann das nationale Cyber Abwehrzentrum
in dem die Sicherheitsorgane des Bundes zur Abwehr elektronische Angriffe auf die IT-Infrastruktur äh zusammenarbeiten sollen und zu diesen Angriffen auf die IT-Infrastruktur gehört dann irgendwie auch Identitätsdiebstahl
und Detoxangriffe, also jetzt sage ich mal, weiß man jetzt nicht, ob da unbedingt
das jetzt so wahnsinnig irre Dinger sind. Zweitausendelf wurde wurden dann die Antiterrorgesetze verlängert. Äh zweitausendzwölf,
äh dass Extremismus und Terrorabwehrzentrum,
äh auch zweitausendzwölf die Verbunddatei, Rechtsextremismus,
Zweitausendfünfzehn wurde das Anti, wurden die Antiterrorgesetze, wie schon gesagt, erneut verlängert und zweitausendsechzehn hatten wir das,
weitere Antiterrorpaket. Das ist das mit den SIM-Karten und wir werden jetzt zweitausendsechzehn nochmal eins bekommen
hat jemand mitgezählt ich habe diesen Überblick da nicht und wollte es genau deshalb mal hier echt einfach mal runterbeten, was wir alles schon,
unternommen haben.
Die Sicherheit herzustell.
Um die Sicherheit herzustellen und wie viel Sicherheit wir eigentlich schon genießen und wie wenig doch tatsächlich passiert ist.
Ja und wie viel Fokus auf Islam und internationalen Terrorismus äh gesetzt wurde und wir also trotzdem ein Jahr erlebt haben, wo Flüchtlingsheime äh,
eins nach dem anderen brennen die NSU in Deutschland ihr Unwesen treibt und man sich wirklich fragt, welche Vorstellung von Terror,
Gefahr eigentlich angemessen wäre und ob man sich hier auf die äh wirklich relevanten Dinge konzentriert.
Ja
Dann ähm macht jetzt gerade die Runde, dass äh Paris und Berlin einen Aktionsplan gegen Verschlüsselung.
Haben vorstellen wollen, um auf der EU-Ebene ähm,
gegen Verschlüsselungen vorzugehen und da hat der Bernhard,
Äh Bernard Casanov, der frankreich französische Innenminister äh am Donnerstag in Paris gesagt, er wolle also am dreiundzwanzigsten August in Paris äh mit
Thomas Demizier über eine neue gemeinsame europäische Initiative sprechen?
Und wir erinnern uns ja aber, dass zweitausendfünfzehn dem Maisier ja lange erzählt hat, dass äh er sich dagegen stemmt.
Hersteller von Handys oder Anbieter von Messengerdiensten zur Einrichtung von Backdoors zu zwingen. Da hat dieser wunderschöne
dieses wunderschöne Formulierung, dass Deutschland der Verschlüsselungsstandort Nummer eins auf der Welt werden solle, seinen Ursprung gefunden, den wir in der digitalen Agenda der Bundesregierung auch wieder sehen.
Und was sie machen ist stattdessen statt jetzt Verschlüsselungen zu schwächen. Der Einsatz,
von Trojanern äh um die äh Maßgabe oder die Idee der Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung zu
folgen. Der Unterschied Quellen, TKÜ und Online-Durchsuchung der wurde glaube ich hier in unseren Sendungen auch schon öfter ausgeführt und ist aber auch nochmal in besagter Sendung,
Mit Constanze Kurz Thema gewesen.
Insofern weiß man nicht genau, was da jetzt äh passieren wird in Frankreich
aber klar ist, dass der Maisier ja, ich glaube die Formulierung war auch von ihm, dass er gesagt hat, wir wollen Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Also diese beiden sehr,
unterschiedlichen Sicherheitskonzepte einmal eine technische Sicherheit in der Kommunikation und dann eben,
diese technische Sicherheit soll für alle da sein, nur nicht für Terroristen. Diese Unterscheidung trifft ja eine Technologie einfach nicht, ne.
Die Quadratur des Kreises.
Ist ja ich weiß nicht, habe ich, mache ich öfter mal nebenbei.
Ich auch laufend. Warum ist ja was zu tun haben.
Ja mit Computern geht das. Ähm und wo wir gerade beim Thema Staatstrojaner sind ähm.
Sind wir bei der neuesten Veröffentlichung von Andre Meister, weil Netzpolitik Org.
Der nämlich äh sagt, dass Bundeskriminalamt hat ja den,
selbst programmierten Trojaner, RCIS heißt ja, das ist Remote, Communication, Interception, Software ähm.
Und den haben sie ja vor einigen Monaten dann da irgendwie vorgestellt und gesagt, ja, voll geil hier, funktioniert und so. Ähm.
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hat den bis heute nicht gesehen, aber der ist auf jeden Fall völlig clean so super Sache. Das Urteil zum BKA-Gesetz war zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch nicht gesprochen. Da hatten sie den schon am Start. Und jetzt stellt sich raus, dass sie ähm.
Gleichzeitig neben ihrer Eigenentwicklung auch den berüchtigten äh Finn Fischer äh der Firma Gamma äh haben.
Hatte Andre schon irgendwie zweitausenddreizehn enthüllt, da ging's irgendwie um hundertsiebenundvierzigtausend Euro für eine Testinstanz, äh wo sie,
immer wieder oder wo sie prüfen wollten, ob die, ob dieser Trojaner mit deutschen Recht vereinbar ist. Und Finn Fischer ist ja dafür bekannt.
Kunden eher in Bereichen zu haben,
wo man jetzt wahrscheinlich weniger strenge Vorgaben für die Trojanisierung von äh missliebigen Personen hat, also die Kunden,
in, sage ich mal, Bereichen, wo es weniger demokratisch zugeht. Äh für die,
die Firma Gamma da ihr Produkt zur Verfügung gestellt hat. Äh da ist wahrscheinlich die Folge mit dem Titel hallo Steffi
eine ganz spannende, ich weiß nicht genau, welche Nummer das war, aber die verlinken wir auch nochmal in den Shownotes. Also Gamma kann man sagen ist wirklich keine kein Unternehmen, mit dem man äh zusammenarbeiten möchte, mit dem man sich schmücken möchte.
Ähm es gab dann da auch mal eine Anfrage dazu, weil Gamma,
gehackt wurde vor einiger Zeit, genauso wie Hacking Team, ähm, beide von Fineers Fischer, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Und äh das würde man ja zumindest mal erwarten, dass so eine,
BKA da hellhörig wird, ob man mit jemandem zusammenarbeiten möchte und die Überwachung von Zielpersonen in Deutschland in die Hände von Leuten legen möchte äh die selber schon aufgemacht wurden.
Und da wird äh äh sagt, dass sagt, schreib
man hier die Analyse des Hackingangriffs auf einen Internetserver der Firma Finn Fischer im Zeitraum vom ersten dritten ersten bis dritten August zweitausendvierzehn in dessen Folge circa vierzig Gigabyte interne Daten der Firma erlangt und im Internet veröffentlicht wurden,
das BKA im November zwanzig vierzehn mit dem Ergebnis abgeschlossen, die Zusammenarbeit mit der Firma fortzusetzen. Ähm.
Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, dass diese Entscheidung, also bei aller
Antipathie, die ich gegen Gamma äh hege oder gegen Pfinnfischer oder unter welchem Namen auch immer diesen Scheiß in in den Ländern vertreiben. Die haben ja unterschiedliche Firmen immer
in den einzelnen Ländern gegründet ähm zur Unterwanderung von Exportkontrollen und so weiter. Aus diesem Heck ist relativ wenig.
Verwertbares Material rausgekommen. Die hatten.
Die Trojaner, die sie da verteilt haben und so, die halt aus diesem Forum, aus diesem Server rausgetragen wurden, die waren alle PGP Verschlüsse. Da hast du also schlechte Karten ähm und sie hatten zum Beispiel
ihr Support-Forum wurde da auch gehackt, wo dann also so Mitarbeiter von Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder Geheimdiensten irgendwie,
Anfragen gestellt haben und die hatten sogar dieses Forum war halt so, dass es,
Quasi die die Leute hatten generische Nutzernamen. Also konntest aus diesem Forum erstmal nicht erkennen wo die Kunden haben,
Außer du hast dann irgendwie so Leute gehabt, die äh dummerweise dann irgendwie schreiben so ja hier bei dem,
äh Mobilfunkanbieter haben wir ein Problem und dann konntest du halt rausfinden, wo der ist. Äh oder einer, der dann irgendwie sagt, ja, hier mit euren Formen ist doch Quatsch, könnt ihr mir bitte an die und die E-Mail-Adresse schreiben, ja? Und dann hat sie hast du halt gesehen,
für, ich glaube das war Schweden, hatte ich damals rausgesucht. Weiß das gar nicht mehr genau
wer da die Trojanereinsätze koordiniert. Das Glasfarbe ein bisschen erhellend.
Und wer so seine Obsekt nicht so ganz im Griff hat.
Ja, wer das halt nicht verstanden hat, ne? Also aber insgesamt gemessen an den vierzig Gigabyte, die da rausgeholt wurden, war das äh relativ unergiebig. Also insofern,
kann ich jetzt auch die Argumentation des BKA verstehen, dass sie sagen, so ja nö.
Die hatten eine Sicherheitslücke, ja, aber da ist jetzt irgendwie, da ist nicht viel Schaden entstanden.
Hallo Steffi war Ausgabe Nummer dreiunddreißig, schon eine Weile her und diese Heckerei, die du ansprichst, hatten wir in Ausgabe hundertzwölf, damals thematisiert.
Die Werbung des Nordens.
Werdung des Notens.
Ja also gut zu sehen, dass bei dieser ganzen Trojanisiererei unser Staat nicht davor zurückschreckt äh mit den,
sage ich mal moralisch, flexibelsten, internationalen Anbietern von äh Trojanisierungssoftware zusammenzuarbeiten,
Aber sie haben also ein weitreichendes Problem mit denen, nämlich, dass sie,
dass dieses Finn Fischer Ding auch mit wiederholten Versuchen einfach nicht äh kompatibel ist mit der deutschen äh Gesetzgebung und sie haben dann.
Ähm diese, also kriegen dann diesen äh Trojaner da und lassen den dann von äh.
Von CSC Deutschland Solutions GmbH nochmal prüfen. Und laut Plan gehen sie jetzt im Moment davon aus, Mitte zwanzig sechzehn die,
Einsatzbereitschaft äh zu erreichen mit diesem Trojaner. Jetzt müssen wir natürlich ein bisschen auf diese Firmen gucken. CSC Deutschlands Solutions GmbH ähm,
ist deshalb bekannt, weil sie.
Weil CSC einer der äh eines der NSA Zulieferunternehmen ist äh die waren bei uns sicherlich auch schon mehrmals Thema, was O.
Man findet jetzt gerade nichts, aber wir hatten das definitiv schon mal. Mh.
Und sie haben auch schon den ersten Digitas äh Staatstrojaner geprüft und weil man da so gute Erfahrungen hatte, mit deren Prüfungen hat man sie zurück nochmal gemacht.
Ich glaube auch in dem Zusammenhang wird dadrüber ge.
Ich habe das in meinem äh Vortrag, den ich vor ein paar Jahren mal gehalten habe, Bullshit Made in Germany äh auch nochmal beleuchtet, dass sie die haben ähm,
Demail geprüft und den Staatstrianer. Also es sind äh toll, ja, mit den Leuten wird's arbeiten, haben halt irgendwie sind sehr NSA-nah und äh das ist echt eine super Idee.
Ähm.
Dummerweise brauchst du oder musst du dich an die wenden, weil du ein BSI zertifiziertes äh Prüflabor hier äh brauchst und da werden dann diese Leute damit. Ähm.
Beauftragt,
Interessanter äh Nebenaspekt ist die Selbstentwicklung ähm dieses RCIS wurde vom BSI zertifizierten Softwareprüflabor, TÜV, Informationstechnik GmbH.
Überprüft und für gut befunden. Äh.
TÜV IT äh TÜV Informationstechnik GmbH ist ähm vom TÜV Nord.
Äh also der TÜV ist ja in Deutschland irgendwie mehrmals aufgeteilt und äh das ist also der TÜV Nord äh der hier äh.
Prüfung vorgenommen hat und Steigbügelhalter dafür war, dass es ein.
Trojaner Selbstentwicklung in Deutschland gibt. Die sind diesen Dienst an der Gesellschaft möchten wir doch hier auch entsprechend würdigen.
Ja, so viel von der äh von der Trojanerfreund. Ach so, ähm die Ratzo, die sind Finnfischer zu haben, ist,
auch im Verlag einer Entdeckung schnell auf eine andere Lösung umsteigen zu können,
Und weiterhin äh hat Finn Fischer natürlich eine sehr viel ähm breiteres äh Infektionsspektrum als äh,
nur dieses RC IS, was hauptsächlich auf Windows Rechner abzielt.
Ja und überhaupt kann man ja glaube ich auch feststellen, dass diesen privaten Sektor einfach die ähm das Arsenal an Zugriffswaffen, was da entwickelt wird, äh eine ganz andere Dimension hat, als
das was so zumindest in Deutschland auf staatlicher Ebene produziert wird oder werden Karten auch nur.
Also man kann sich auf Backplanet äh das Arsenal da anschauen ähm Finfinficer,
Macht sich dann zum Beispiel auch Gedanken darüber, okay, wie, wie infizierst du das Opfer? Haben also da Angriffstools, um ein ein nicht bewachten Computer äh anzugreifen und zu.
Äh zu übernehmen und die Trojanerinfektion anzubringen. Ähm die verkaufen dir auch irgendwelche äh GSM, Abhöranlagen, das dann aber in der Regel so im,
Weiterverkauf. Also wir haben ein sehr breites Spektrum im Angebot und,
diese Trojanergeschichte ist eines davon und ähm die ist Teil einer ganzen Suite, äh wo sie auch irgendwie keine Ahnung, die geben dir einen so einen Infektions äh Server, das heißt du du schiebst im Prinzip.
Beim.
Beim Telekommunikationsanbieter so ein Ding ins Regal und das in macht eine gezielte Infektion von Rechnern hinter diesen ähm,
hinter diesem Anschluss, also kannst quasi sagen, hier Anschluss Britlove
und wenn der, wenn das Windows-Update im Hintergrund wieder Updates zieht, dann leite den mal um und bring mal stattdessen eine Trojanerinfektion an. Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ich habe jetzt extra Wundersuppe genommen. Ich gehe davon aus, oder ich hoffe, dass zumindest die Betriebssystemupdater inzwischen mal
ihre Software,
auf Signatur prüfen und diese Art des Angriffs nicht mehr möglich ist oder nicht mehr so einfach möglich ist, aber sowas verkaufen die auch. Also ganz äh,
Einmal das komplette Programm. Auch toll, ja.
So, dann haben wir noch einen kleinen Nachtrag zu einer Geschichte, die uns vor ein paar äh Wochen hier ausführlich beschäftigt hat, rund um den Fall Jayclub Apple Baum.
Gab's jetzt,
weitere Bewegungen im Torumfeld und ein passender Artikel dazu auf Zeit online. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie ihr ihn geschrieben habt.
Christian Fuchs.
Äh
Vielleicht fangen wir ganz kurz an mit den mit der mit der Torveröffentlichung. Äh die war nämlich zeitlich davor. Ähm und zwar hatte.
Sherry Steel, dann äh gesagt so äh.
Die Chefin des Torprojektes. Neu.
Die neue junge Geschäftsführerin, also die Dienstjung. Ähm hat gesagt, ja, wir haben ja gesagt, wir untersuchen jetzt hier unsere ähm.
Internen Strukturen nachdem Jakob Apple Baum das Topprojekt verlassen hat
und wir haben ich habe ja dazu aufgefordert, äh sich an mich zu wenden äh wenn man irgendwie schlechte Erfahrungen mit diesem Menschen gemacht hat und so weiter und wir untersuchen das jetzt hier
ordentlich, das hat sieben Wochen gedauert und sie haben jetzt Ende Juli dann veröffentlich diese Untersuchung ist jetzt abgeschlossen. Ähm.
Viele Menschen im Torprojekt haben Vorfälle berichtet, wo sie ähm.
Eingeschüchtert, gebulliert oder bloß gestellt wurden oder ihnen Angst gemacht wurde? Ähm.
Und viele haben unerwünschtes, sexuell aggressives Verhalten von ihm erfahren. Ähm.
Und dann steht da noch ein Satz drin, die Untersuchung hat zwei weitere Personen.
Identifiziert, die sich äh.
Also die ein unangemessenes Verhalten gezeigt hätten und die jetzt nicht mehr länger bei Tor sind.
Entscheidend ist an dieser Stelle, hier steht nirgendwo, dass ähm Jakob Apple Baum jemanden vergewaltigt hätte. Und.
Diese die Untersuchung des Vergewaltigungsvorwurfes ist einfach mal definitiv.
Negativ verlaufen. Es gibt keinen ähm keine Zeugen dafür, dass Jakob Apple Baum einen Menschen vergewaltigt hätte. Und das ist natürlich ein sehr entscheidender Unterschied. Es gibt.
Beschissenes Verhalten? Es gibt sexuelle Belästigung.
Und es gibt Vergewaltigungen und es ist wichtig und sinnvoll, dass man diese Dinge klar voneinander trennt und auch klar voneinander definiert. Spaßfakt am Rande,
Die beiden Personen, die jetzt nicht mehr bei Tor arbeiten? Waren Entlastungszeugen.
In dem Fall der Vergewaltigungen, die auf dieser Seite Jaycop Apple Baum dort net äh geschildert wird, wo eine Person sagt, sie sei äh irgendwie ähm bewusstlos bei ihm zu Hause
vor einer Gruppe von Menschen vergewaltigt worden und.
Es gibt eben in dieser Gruppe von Menschen keinen, der sagt, da hat eine Vergewaltigung stattgefunden.
Und das Statement dieser Person geht ja auch damit los, dass ihr wie gesagt bis vor Kurzem wusste ich nicht, dass,
auch eine Vergewaltigung ist. Äh das habe ich jetzt erst erfahren, dass sie vergewaltigt wurde. So und da sieht man natürlich schon relativ.
Klar, ein paar Wochen später, was da offenbar passiert ist. Ja, da ist halt sind halt ein paar Personen wohl sehr weit über äh das definierte Ziel hinausgeschossen. Ähm hier.
Klar den an den Vorwurf einer Vergewaltigung zu machen? Und es gibt eben offenbar eine Untersuchung.
Es muss auch festgehalten werden, dass diese Untersuchung trotzdem zu dem Ergebnis kommt, dass.
Das Verhalten von Jaycop an vielen Fällen nicht in Ordnung war, dass diese Untersuchung zu dem Ergebnis kommt, dass sie.
Dass es gut war, was geschehen ist, also dass sie ihn rausgeworfen haben und dass sie dazu weiter entstehen.
Ähm aber es wird eben nicht ganz so klar gemacht, dass äh dass eben der Vorwurf einer Vergewaltigung offenbar hier ähm.
Nicht aufrecht gehalten werden kann und das ist wichtig, ähm dass dann auch klarzustellen und den Menschen von diesem Vorwurf, der eben ja vernichtend ist. Ähm.
Auch ähm ja zu befreien.
Ja, wir hatten ja schon am.
Weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wann jetzt die Sendung war, aber als als wir das sozusagen so breit diskutiert haben, eigentlich von vornherein auch so ein bisschen diese,
Problematik äh auch versucht darzustellen, dass äh es zunächst einmal eben Behauptungen waren, dass einfach.
Das ist auch ja schon von Anfang an relativ viel Kritik an dieser Vorgehensweise mit dieser Webseite, mit seinem Namen et cetera, Fotos von ihm
die ganze Darstellung war schon sehr
sag mal dramatisierend und das natürlich dann eben die Verifizierbarkeit einfach dieser Storys sehr schwierig ist, diesen dann halt erstmal im Raum und in dem Moment wo das im Raum ist, äh ja äh ist der Elefant sozusagen im Porzellanladen schon ganz
ordentlich unterwegs und später wird natürlich wenig darüber gesprochen,
was in irgendeiner Form unhaltbare oder im Zweifelsfall sogar auch widerlegbare Behauptungen sind und diese Problematik besteht halt in solchen Fällen immer.
Uns auch dazu von vorne rein gebracht hat, da eben auch einfach möglichst,
neutral, so neutral, wie man da eben jetzt auch äh sein kann. Dazu stehen zu sagen, okay, wir sind jetzt hier in so einer äh Heaset äh Situation, in der einfach Behauptungen drin sind,
man äh tendiert dazu leicht äh schnell.
Sich auch so quantitativ akkumulierende äh Statements schnell äh Glauben zu schenken, einfach weil sie sozusagen in einer Masse oder so einer konzertierten Aktion vorgetragen werden.
Weil eine bestimmte Glaubhaftigkeit mit sich bringt und
bestreiten, dass die anderen Berichte oder vielleicht auch die Mehrheit dieser Berichte in irgendeiner Form
halt zutrifft, ne? Nur absolut kann man eben nicht sagen nur weil das Hälzer so steht ist es jetzt so und das das macht eben einfach die Bewertung solcher Fälle ebenso schwierig.
Dazu wird's also ja ich glaub ich denke.
Viel mehr ist dazu leider nichts zu sagen oder ist kann man da nichts zu sagen? Ich glaube nicht, dass das sehr zurückblickend insgesamt besonders.
Toll gelaufen ist alles.
Nee, kann man nicht sagen. Für alle Beteiligten nicht.
Und äh tja, also diese Sache mit den also es gibt natürlich dann auch, muss man der Vollständigkeit halber natürlich schon auch sagen.
Wir werden dann kommen natürlich dann Leute und sagen, das ist aber irgendwie komisch, ne? Also dieser Astorge irgendwie und dieser Apple-Baum und so äh und äh ein Schelm wäre Böses dabei denkt, dass die dass die alle immer.
Mit solchen Dingen irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit dann untergehen. Ähm nun äh,
Ich denke also das haben wir glaube ich auch in der in der ersten Sendung, wo wir uns mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben auch so gesagt, so charakterlich passt das schon dazu, dass die jetzt sich mal Grenzen anderer Menschen ähm nicht immer besonders taktvoll respektiert haben,
Aber auch da ist eben also Vergewaltigung ist eben kein kein Witz, ne? Das ist das ist halt echt ernster Scheiß. Und ähm.
Kann nur sagen, dass ich es sehr wichtig finde, da eben auch äh zu unterscheiden, was ist was und was, welcher, welcher Tatbestand wann, wo erfüllt ist.
Wenn der nicht erfüllt ist, dann kann man eben auch diesen Vorwurf nicht erheben. Sollen wir nochmal über was Schönes reden, Tim.
Ja, das wäre jetzt ganz angemessen, ne? Gab, gab's ja auch, gab ja auch was Schönes,
Haben wir ja schon äh auch eingangs eingeleitet. Hackerurlaub im August äh immer sehr äh prominent. Die Sommerveranstaltungen. Mittlerweile kann man ja schon von einem Plural sprechen.
Es gab dieses Jahr das dritte Mal und ich glaube wir waren beide das erste Mal da, ne? Äh ein ein Huckercamp.
Oder weiß gar nicht, ob der Name jetzt sozusagen richtig ist.
Parate Diskussion, ja? Also es gab eine Veranstaltung in England, die hieß und ich weiß man gar nicht, haben wir überhaupt angekündigt, glaube wir haben.
Nee, haben wir nicht ange.
Haben wir nicht angekündigt, äh sehe Elektromagnetik field. Ähm das ist eine Open Air,
technologisch aber auch
politisch und wie wir sagen, halt jetzt einfach mal sein Lobhucker-Camp äh orientierte Veranstaltungen, die jetzt das dritte Mal stattgefunden hat
die äh ist nämlich alle zwei Jahre, so wie sich das bisher abzeichnet und die sich von vornherein in diesen freien Slot gedrängt hat, der
immer offen war
wenn man eben nur nach Holland und nach Deutschland schaut, wo halt immer so die holländische Community und Community sich dann immer so gegenseitig den Stock in die Hand gegeben hat und gesagt hat, so jetzt seid ihr dran,
und jeder macht alle vier Jahre was und dann blieb dann eben,
immer ein Jahr frei zum Allgemeinen erholen, das ist jetzt nicht mehr so, aber jetzt gibt's irgendwie das EMF-Camp und ich muss sagen
nachdem drei Tagen die äh wir dann dort waren äh bin ich doch sehr beeindruckt und und fand das eine eine sehr,
wohlorganisierte Veranstaltungen die ja viel vertraut ist mit sich brachte aber eben auch diese kleinen Unterschiede,
äh hatte, die dann immer da sind, wenn das mal andere äh soziale Gruppen äh organisieren und,
Das war äh Schönermann. Tausendsiebenhundertfünfzig Leute da.
Mir ist jetzt die offizielle Besucherzahl. Mag einem erstmal wenig vorkommen. Ich denke, das Interesse wäre auch größer gewesen, allerdings das ist schon mal so eine Besonderheit, hat sich die äh Orga des EMF.
Von vornherein auf diese Zahl beschränkt. Ähm die Zahl war so ein bisschen,
erfunden, weil also nicht erfunden, weil's nicht stimmt, sondern man hat von vornherein beschlossen, sich auf diese Zahl zu beschränken,
weil es zuvor tausendzweihundert Leute waren, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere und davor weiß ich nicht so genau, eine dreistellige Zahl, wo man eben gesagt hat, wir wollen einen kontrolliertes Wachstum dieses dieser Veranstaltung haben, damit auch wir organisatorisch.
Sozusagen ein kontrolliertes Wachstum dem entgegenstellen können,
Und so kam man dann eben auf die Zahl, also man hat einfach so und so viel Prozent obendrauf geschlagen und dann war das halt so.
Das Gelände hätte sicherlich auch noch Potential gehabt, locker, weiß nicht.
Mehr.
Mehr hätten da jetzt sicherlich mühelos äh reingepasst, da war auf jeden Fall noch genug Freifläche und äh auch so von der Kapazität von allem. Äh wer da sicherlich noch einiges gegangen,
aber äh gut, das war halt eine bewusste Entscheidung. Ja und dann gab's ganz interessantes Programm und auch ganz interessantes Rahmenprogramm.
Also was ich, was ich da feststelle, du findest eigentlich also Hacker kommt, findet da findest du auf dieser Seite nicht,
Ja und ich habe auch äh irgendwann mal, weil war ich mit
jemanden im Gespräch und der sagt dann so, oh, wie gefällt's dir und ich sehe ja großartig und ja, wo kommst du her, Berlin und? Ah, okay und ah wie was führt dich hierher und dann habe ich gesagt, ja ich
ähm sammel so die Hacker-Camps, ne? Die besuche ich dann immer und dann denken wir so, was für Camps.
Und dieser Begriff Hackercamp war da einfach den Leuten nicht geläufig. Das war die.
Das war da nicht so. Du hast es auch von der die Szene war auf eine gewisse Weise angenehm anders ähm.
Oder wie heißt jetzt so großes großes Wort aber die haben das war einfach glaube ich so.
Ein offeneres Ding, wo jetzt wo nicht unbedingt so eine Community äh oder eine Szene sich trifft und sagt, wir sind aber jetzt hier die Hacker,
und das ist das,
konstituierende Merkmal für uns alle hier. Wir äh wir nehmen uns als Hacker wahr. Ähm sondern waren halt alle möglichen Leute, die sich irgendwie für Dinge interessiert haben und es gab halt viele.
So Bastelein, Maker, äh Crafter, also der irgendwie dieser äh Schmiede-Workshop oder so, ne? Schmiede Village. Konntest hingehen, hast du dann irgendwie ein Stück Eisen mit dem Hammer da drauf rumgehauen, konntest du dir irgendwie was schmieden, ja?
Ding, Ding, Ding, Ding, Ding, Ding, gegen, gegen, gegen, gegen, ich war froh, dass ich auf der anderen Seite gekämpft habe.
Ähm.
Ja, also man muss sagen, EMF.
Großartige Veranstaltung, muss ich wirklich sagen, eine großartige Veranstaltung.
IMF-Camp war äh also zieht ihre äh seine Community im Wesentlichen aus zwei Bereichen, nämlich einerseits einer Gaming-Community,
Andererseits auch aus einer Maker-Space-Community und das ist so ein Phänomen, was wir jetzt ohnehin überall in äh der Welt, aber eben jetzt auch sehr stark in Europa äh sehen, zumindest äh dort und wir werden auch gleich nochmal über Holland reden
dass sich eigentlich in den letzten Jahren
eben diese Spaces gebildet haben, die sich eher als Maker-Spaces und auch in dem Sinne wiederum nicht als äh Hackerspaces äh verstehen. Es gibt da eine gewisse Berührungsangsangst mit dem Begriff, die sicherlich äh auch kulturelle Gründe hat,
In England kann man sich das ja nun sehr gut vorstellen und es gab ja,
nie auch etwas Vergleichbares, wie zum Beispiel den CCC jetzt in äh in England oder,
Britannien überhaupt. Es gibt halt Privacy International, es gibt so einzelne Gruppen, aber die haben einfach.
Nicht auch nur ansatzweise irgendwie so eine ähnliche kulturelle äh Ausprägung, wie das jetzt eben der Club in,
Deutschland gemacht hat, also dieses ganze Hackerphänomen ist schon immer noch ein sehr, sehr deutsches äh Phänomen, also so wie wir's verstehen, ist es ein sehr deutsches Phänomen, was zwar abstrahlt,
aber mitnichten überall der Standard ist. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das alles extrem kompatibel gewesen, also von den Leuten her, man trifft halt die Art von Leuten, die man auch bei uns auf dem,
äh traf und in Zukunft treffen wird, schlicht äh aufgeschlossene Leute, die einfach,
ein sehr in die investigativen Grundcharakter an den Tag legen und dementsprechend waren halt auch die Vorträge äh im selben Maße unterhaltsam, also da waren wirklich ein,
paar wirklich gute Talks dabei. Das Wok des CCC war auch wieder vor Ort. Dementsprechend gibt's auch die ganzen Vorträge,
online mit wenigen Ausnahmen, die nicht aufgezeichnet werden wollten, wo man nur noch gleich verstanden hat, warum. Ähm ja,
und was hat mir noch gefallen? Also es gab so ein paar äh britische Eigenschaften, die Bar ähm,
sah jetzt zwar nicht sehr cosy aus, aber hatte irgendwie eine.
Unfassbare Bandbreite an Biersorten äh parat, also sie haben da irgendwie wirklich,
in größeren Teilmengen so Craft äh aus der Craft Bierszene halt Sorten reingetragen, also man kriegt sie da halt nicht so das Standardbier, sondern es gab halt ausschließlich
Bier, kleinerer Blu-Ries, die halt, ja, immer noch sehr englisch, äh, britisch waren
und daneben da auch mit einer korrekten Zapfanlage bezahlt worden,
Mit Apple Pay, mir ein Bier kaufen. Was war? Fand ich auch so, einundzwanzigstes Jahrhundertmäßig, ich meine da äh hat sich da irgendwie äh keiner gemeldet, nur trotz drüber gewundert, weil so Contact Les Payment ist in England einfach mal Standard,
Aber äh so uns äh rückständige deutsche äh hat es natürlich dann gleich beeindruckt mich zumindest,
ja, also das ist sozusagen so ein äh äh Phänomen, es gab ganz korrekte Essensständer,
Ähm es war ähm dann nachts auch äh interessant illuminiert,
anders als bei uns, wo ja sehr viel äh auf so allgemeine Gestaltungen gelegt wird.
Was da eher sagen wir mal auch mehr Ausdruck des Pragmatismus. Ich fand zum Beispiel die Art und Weise, wie ihren äh Netzwerkinfrastruktur verlegt haben, finde ich
extrem scharming, hören wir ja immer viel am äh buddeln und unter die Erde verlegen sind, haben die einfach äh konsequent
mit so Stangen, also mit Masten gearbeitet, die Masten alle erstmal schön an die Wege gelegt und da dann halt die Kabel, also sowohl Strom als auch Glasfaser rangemacht und dann mit so einer einfachen Methode erstmal ein Gabelstapler
eine kleine Stange in den Boden gedrückt,
also ohne auch großbohrereien, einfach so mit dem Stapler äh Fett in den Boden fettig, da dann zwei Schälen rangemacht in den großen Mast einfach hochgeklappt
mit der ganzen Kabellage und dann war das halt sowohl die Strau Strom und Netzwerkbasisinfrastruktur als eben auch, weil
auch noch mit dran, eine Lichterkette, sodass eben alle Wege dann eben auch gleichmäßig gut ausgeleuchtet waren. Das war,
praktisch sah okay aus, war halt jetzt nicht so hübsch, aber war äh so in seiner Gesamtanmutung,
machte das irgendwie noch ein charming Eindruck, fand ich so.
Ich fand das total schön mit diesen mit diesen weißen Ballons da, die haben doch so irgendwie so ein bisschen ja diese Lampen, die da dranhängen.
Ballons. Aber keine Balance, das war einfach nur Glühbirnen.
Nee, der war nochmal irgendwie, dann waren das große Glübien oder so. Ich fand das sah schön aus. Ich war oben auf dem Lüger, habe da runtergeguckt, das hatte so ein bisschen Dorfcharakter, das war ganz nett. Ich fand das schön.
Weißt du, die Sachen ist ja nicht, dass es nicht nicht schick aussah, es war halt so ein bisschen anders, aber es war halt auch eine eine
beeindruckend pragmatische Entscheidung das so zu machen, weil es war super schnell, das war dann am Montagabend, also am, am ersten Abbautag war das schon komplett runtergenommen.
Weil es so auch so schnell wieder äh sich rückführen ließ. Ja und ähm das hat ganz gut funktioniert und dann ja genau, was ich noch sagen wollte, dann,
Und dann ist es auch so, dass ein Teil des Budgets explizit in die Förderung von Projekten gegangen ist von bestimmten Makers-Basis, die gesagt haben, wir wollen hier eine tolle Installation machen
die dann auch ein bisschen cofinanziert wurden, sodass sie sich eben dann diesen Aufwand auch leisten konnten. Und da waren auch ein paar echt äh nette Sachen dabei. Also zwei will ich vielleicht mal herausstellen. Das eine, was mir sehr gut gefiel war, diese
riesigen LED
Dinger äh dieses Dance Dance Revolutionartige Ding, hast du das mal ausprobiert. War so drei lange Stangen, die so, weiß nicht, fünf, sechs, sieben Meter hoch waren
Komplett mit einer LED.
Klar.
So wie man das eben von diesen DDR mit Mittanzspielchen äh kennt.
Wo dann sozusagen ein Song abgespielt wurde und dann so quasi bisschen so wie Midi Noten aber halt mehr so den die eigentlichen Rhythmus und Charakter des Songs interpretierenden.
Das das Wort nach dem du suchst, die die DDR Mittanzspiele, die der Tim meint, äh die heißen Gitarr Hero. Das ist doch dieses PlayStation-Spiel, wo man das jetzt auch für.
Hast du genau diese Timeline, Entschuldigung, ich bin ja äh alt. Äh hast recht. Ähm,
beim Tanzen ist es ja genauso, dass du sozusagen so ein so ein so eine Kette von Instruktionen hast bei
Du musst es dann halt, um dieses Spiel quasi mitzuspielen, äh die Farben, die dann eben von oben herunter äh sich ergossen an dieser LED-Stange musstest du dann eben mit entsprechenden Tastern, die ein paar Meter davor aufgebaut waren in der Dunkelheit, dann irgendwie so nach äh,
und das war grandios.
Ja, super geil. Jetzt hast du erzählt, dass es das, was da zuerst gesehen hat, jetzt kann ich das nicht mehr selber bauen und zu tun, als hätte ich mir das ausgedacht.
Sorry. Hast du das andere Ding auch noch äh zur Kenntnis genommen mit diesen Tischtennis? Schläger mit dem über dem.
Ja, das Feuerpong. Ja, das war also das war äh groß, ey, das war wirklich cool, das war halt irgendwie eine in in einer Reihe stehende ähm so Gasbrenner, Flammenwerfer eigentlich, wie heißt sowas eigentlich.
Kommt Feuer raus.
Ja, das war so elektrisch gezündete Gas.
Fontänen, Feuer.
Fontänen. Genau, die so in so einer langen Kette standen, das waren irgendwie so, weiß nicht, fünfzehn, zwanzig Stück vielleicht.
Nee, waren zehn.
Nur, ah okay.
Äh es stehen in einer Reihe und wenn man jetzt ganz kurz einmal Gas gibt und das Ding zündet, dann kommt ja so ein Feuerball raus von unten nach oben. Und die stehen also in einer Reihe. Das ganze Ding ist abgeschirmt und an beiden Enden stehen Leute mit so überdimensionierten
ähm Tischtennisschlägern, in denen vermutlich so ein Axelerometer drin ist.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Mhm.
Und äh jetzt schlägt also schlägt die eine Person auf und dann schießt fällt,
fliegt quasi ein Feuerball von,
Von der einen zur anderen Person, in dem einfach diese in einer Reihe stehenden Geräte immer einen Feuerball hochschießen. Und wenn dann in richtigen Moment das Ding am Ende ist, dann muss die andere Person schlagen,
Und äh dann geht der geht dieser Ball zurück und da spielt man dann halt Pong
Äh bis äh bis einer äh einer der beiden Personen äh nicht im richtigen Moment schlägt. Und das Ding war auch auf Geschwindigkeitssensitiv, also wenn man Teste geschlagen hat, dann ging es auch schneller hin,
Äh ein großartiges, eine großartige Installation, die da halt wirklich jeden Abend für viele Stunden den Leuten Spaß gemacht hat. Und das haben da irgendwie einfach Besucher angeschleppt, ne? Oder ich.
Das sind dann halt diese Meckerspaces, die dann eben diese Community.
Haben die gemaket. Ja, wir haben hier richtig gemäkt. Also ich war äh.
War durch von von vielen Spielereien dort äh sehr beeindruckt. Auch so kleine äh versteckte Geschichten wie hinten diese Buchstaben äh so am Hügel standen die ja dann so,
Die Buchstaben IMF sechzehn und äh die wurden von unterschiedlichen Gruppen dann beigesteuert und zum Beispiel die die eins ähm,
Hatte halt ein HTP Server äh und wenn man die Seite besucht hat, hat sie es halt das Ding geblinkt und man konnte dem auch andere Blinksequenzen in dem Gat-Parameter übergeben. Und dann wurde ähm.
Gab es natürlich auch ein Batch. Übrigens auch ein super cooles äh supercooles Batch. Ich habe schon mir schon Sachen gekauft, um da mit zu spielen. Ähm LED-Schläuche halt und ähm.
Äh das hatte unter anderem WLAN, sehr schönes Display und.
Eigentlich unglaublich einen App Store. Die haben dieses Batch gebaut und haben einen App Store gehabt. Äh man konnte also,
Also es gab quasi eine Seite, wo man dann seine App hochladen konnte, dann gab es ein Review-Prozess
Und äh dann gab es auf dem Betch die Applibory, der dann sagte, ja, hier gibt's eine App, wird sie installieren, alles klar. Dann hat er die runtergeladen und installiert. Und die hatten eine
hat eine Unmengen an Apps innerhalb kürzester Zeit, weil dieses Batch und das fand ich also so richtig cool. Ähm nicht irgendeine.
Doch eher ungewohnte Prozessorchitektur hat, die man dann wohl in zehn mal programmieren kann oder so, mit irgendwelchen Computern, die man sich erstmal bauen muss. Ähm,
sondern das hatte ein Micropreifen-Interpreter. Und das heißt, die Apps, die man da geschrieben hat, konnte man in Peißen schreiben. Es gab dann so ein paar Librarys eben für HTTP Reques, für.
Äh für alle möglichen, also gab eingeschränktes Set an an Librarys, die es dann da schon so gab und ähm,
Damit konnte man dann eine App schreiben und dadurch, dass es dieses Peißen ist, was einfach eine eine sehr ähm,
ordentliche und einfache Einsteigersprache ist. Ähm,
konnten halt alle sofort losschreiben, du musstest diese App Apps nicht kompelieren oder sonst was, was das Ding einfach drangesteckt, dann war es ein USB
Mastorage Device, dann hast du deine peifen Datei da drauf kopiert und hast die ausgeführt. Und da gab's beeindruckend viele Spielereien innerhalb des ersten Tages. Nachdem das Ding ausgegeben wurde,
Ähm und diesen diesen Effekt, der ist natürlich echt großartig. Ähm.
Da bin ich zum ersten Mal auf dieses Konzept Microprisen ähm aufmerksam geworden und muss sagen, das war eine eine
großartige Entscheidung, um halt quasi den Leuten da an Ort und Stelle das Spielen mit dem äh mit dem Bad zu ermöglichen. Und ähm.
Feines Spielzeug, kann ich nur sagen, echt schön.
Den Einfluss der Gamerkultur, der war dann auch bei diesem Batch zu spüren, weil es war ja nicht nur so ein Namensbach, sondern er hatte sozusagen die Form eines eines eines und äh auch die Controllermöglichkei
Curser Controls und AB Buttons und so weiter drauf und.
Gameboy war das oder nicht? Was ist ein Depad.
Na so ein Controller für wie man das eben so von Nintendo senden,
und so weiter kennen, genau und dann hast du sozusagen da eben so ein Display in der Mitte, AB rechts und
Pfeil nach oben, links, rechts, auf der linken Seite und damit kann man halt sowohl durch's Menü durch navigieren, als auch das Ding eben als Controller für was auch immer benutzen, wo ich jetzt keine Anwendung gesehen habe, aber das war auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee.
Nee, also das, das war wirklich toll. Ich war beeindruckt. Man kommt ja dann auch so ein bisschen, ja
vielleicht ein bisschen hochnäsig so von den CC Camps und sagten na ja mal schauen was den hier nach dem Brexit noch gelingt und äh.
Meine Herren, also ich.
Da ist auf jeden Fall was am Start. Ich habe auch noch äh ein weiteres interessantes äh Gespräch geführt mit dem äh Organisator, dem Johnty.
Ähm also ein Dreierteam muss man dazu sagen. Der Johnty war da aber von Anfang an dabei und hat auch irgendwie eine schöne Abschlussrede äh gehalten äh Öffnungsveranstaltung äh war ich leider nicht.
Und habe mich auch ein bisschen danach nochmal äh erkundigt, wie denn das eigentlich so mit der Inhaltsauswahl gelaufen ist und das fand ich auch sehr interessant. Und zwar war das so, dass äh es gab halt so ein.
Corfu Peppers natürlich, der auch schon relativ früh rausging. Glaube, im Januar oder so oder früher sogar noch. Und,
Die Contentauswahl lief so, dass alle Talks, die eingereicht wurden, zunächst einmal von einem Team,
anonymisiert wurden. Das heißt, man hat darauf geachtet, dass,
der die eigentliche Beschreibung, die letzten Endes den Reviewern vorgelegt wird, möglichst keine Hinweise auf,
Herkunftsname.
Geschlecht et cetera ähm der der vortragenden bietet. Was auch dazu geführt hat, dass in diesem Prozess auch die Beschreibungen der Talks, das war wohl schon mal so eine der Erfahrungen.
Möglichst auch dann immer wieder noch verbessert werden muss, weil in dem Moment, wo man das offensichtliche, diesen persönlichen Bezug
dann einfach nicht mehr drin haben will, muss man dann eben zwangsläufig sehr viel genauer erklären, worum denn nun eigentlich dieser Talk sich äh drehen soll und
und was das Ding ist. Häufig hat man das ja, dass Leute dann einfach so Kraft ihrer äh bekannten Persönlichkeit einfach sagen, ja hier, mein Projekt, das la und das äh entfällt halt an der Stelle. Natürlich gab es einen Teil von Talks,
die sagen wir mal jetzt auch aktiv angeworben wurden et cetera
trotz alledem dem war es wohl so, dass neunzig Prozent aller Talks durch diesen Anonymisierungsprozess durchgegangen sind, was im Übrigen darin resultierte, dass unter anderem auch äh eine sechzig, vierzig Geschlechterverteilung war, also sechzig
Prozent der Talks wurden von Männern gehalten, vierzig Prozent Frauen.
Keine Ahnung, ob jetzt durch diese zehn Prozent die angeworben wurden, äh dadurch äh nochmal eine weitere Verzerrung standfallen, aber.
Was zählt hier, was ich hier interessant finde, äh ist dieser Prozess ähm den ich für,
sehr, sehr, sehr interessant und äh nachams würde ich halte. Äh es ist im Übrigen auch Software entstanden, weil,
ist da sozusagen nicht die passende Software für äh gab, um das alles zu managen, was auch alles Open Source veröffentlicht,
entweder worden ist oder werden wird, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau. Es wird da wohl demnächst auch nochmal ein Blogpost äh geben von der Orga,
und äh ja, da bin ich sehr gespannt und ich hoffe auch, dass ich dadurch äh dieses ganze Universum der Veranstaltungsunterstützenden Softwareprojekte auch noch weiter verbessert. Also da waren die wirklich gut.
Hast du auch die Software gesehen von der Bar.
Bar hatte eine eigene Webseite. Man konnte jederzeit den kompletten Lagerfüllstand äh sozusagen nachfragen. Also ich habe da nachge.
Feststellt, so es gibt noch zehn Flaschen Clubmate, drei Flaschen Cola und so und so viel äh Pins äh der dieser und jeder Sorte Craft Bier war noch äh verfügbar, weil das halt alles in diesen eltonischen,
Kaufbezahlprozess an der Bar äh mit eingebunden war. Fantastisch. Also da hatten die wirklich äh viele Register gezogen. Äh da kann sich auch der Club nochmal diverse Schallbletten abschneiden.
Und alles was äh alles was irgendwie online aufrufbar war, warte dann auch am am Samstagabend noch eine eine Batch-App, ne? Also äh diese diese blinkende Eins,
konnte hatte natürlich da eine App, dann konntest du auf deinem Bett den Knopf drücken und oben aufm aufm Berg hattest, hat die eins geblinkt. Das äh
so, ne? Ein anderer hatte dann, die hatte, glaube ich, dich in diesen Store gepusht, ähm hat irgendwie die aktuelle Bandbreitennutzung des Camps irgendwie bei sich als Graf äh oder oder in Zahlen auf dem Display stehen gehabt, der war halt vom,
vom dortigen äh Nock. Ähm.
Das Nock wiederum muss man sagen, ist schon mittlerweile eher eine internationale Veranstaltung.
Nicht nur unseres auch die Holländer äh also es gibt da schon immer so ein Holland, England, Deutschland, äh, Mix im Nock und das Nock ist mittlerweile glaube ich bei solchen Veranstaltungen die größte Konstante in diesem ganzen Spiel.
Ja, einer der Hauptorganisatoren ist ja auch äh seit Jahren im äh CSC Nock immer aktiv. Daher ja auch die oder daher kenne ich diese.
Leute. Ähm ich wollte nochmal ganz kurz auf die Vorträge, weil die natürlich auch so ein bisschen ähm.
Das spiegelte sich das auch wieder, dieses Machen Ding, ne? Also zum Beispiel Howei Bild, my Diesel Power Motorcycle, hat ein Motorrad mit einem Dieselmotor gebaut und hält darüber einen Vortrag. Ähm.
Dann ging's irgendwie um äh wie man eine wie funktionierende Raketen.
Aber was ich wirklich am äh am spannendsten fand, war Free Deep Printing the Worlds, Mose, oh nee, Scheiße. Falsch, falsch. Ist aber äh es ist genauso, warte mal ganz kurz. Ähm.
Es ist äh Moment, jetzt habe ich.
Meiste for Diesing.
Nee, Capute, the Worlds first Working Refreshible Malta Line Brei Display.
Multilein, keine Ahnung. Ähm.
Kommt drauf an, in welche welchen Akzent ich versuche zu sprechen, welch den französischen äh Akzent hier.
Machst du auf Schottisch? Display.
So, die haben ähm ein ähm also Menschen, die blind sind ähm.
Können ähm unter Umständen, die mit der mit den Fingern gelesene Blindenschrift lesen.
Das ist also quasi sind die Buchstaben kodiert in Form von Erhebungen,
aus der Oberfläche. Das gibt's also dann als geprägtes Papier und man sieht das auch in Fahrstühlen, kennt man das vielleicht oder äh an Denkmälern oder so, steht dann auch immer nochmal sowas dran. Dann kann man da mit dem Finger drüber gehen. Und die Menschen äh das ist eine Schrift,
die Menschen lesen können. Und zwar sehr gut, müsste er erstaunlich, wie schnell äh sie ihre Finger darüber bewegen. Ähm wenn jetzt solche,
Leute einen Computer bedienen wollen.
Dann gibt es da irgendwie so ein, so dass das Standardmodell, was du dann irgendwie kriegst, ist irgendwie so ein mehrtausend Euro kostendes Gerät, was du vor deinem Computer stellst und was dir dann irgendwie
drei Zeilen oder sowas ausgeben kann. Ja, also relativ wenig und du navigierst also dann sehr, sehr schwierig auf einem Bildschirm
Ähm weil ihr dann weiß nicht benutzt, also ein Textbrowser oder so und du hast ja ohnehin sage ich mal nicht die Möglichkeit einen Überblick zu erfassen.
Ähm aber dadurch, dass du nur drei Zeilen hast oder oder zwei sogar nur. Ähm.
Kannst du den auch nicht ergreifen. Und was die gemacht haben, ist, sie haben im Prinzip einfach iPad Größe brei gemacht. Und dann kannst du ähm,
mit den Fingern wirklich auch mal schnell drüber gehen ohne rechts noch mit dem Curser irgendwie zu versuchen zu navigieren und kannst also Augen.
Als Augen öffnend wurde es halt für die von den Leuten beschrieben, die das getestet haben, dass sie endlich mal so einen Computer erfassen, da ist eine Welt da draußen und das ist eine ganze DIN A4-Seite, äh die in diesem lärmenden Gerät steckt und ähm dieser Bildschirm, der da ist, äh,
in der gleichen Größe
gibt's denn für die Leute auch was? Und die streben da einen Retail-Preis von irgendwie fünfhundert Pfund an und diese äh ich sage mal, das Kassenmodell, was du da irgendwie kriegst. Äh das kostet natürlich irgendwie ein Vermögen.
Und alles schön aus dem 3D Drucker mit Laser Cutter und so weiter.
Haben Sie selber entwickelt und ja das ist also echt 'ne mit mit Steppermotoren und so echt mal geil, dass du denkst, okay, da setzt sich halt einer hin und äh,
Denkt sicher, dass das ein Ding, was man mal lösen muss in dieser Gesellschaft. Und in dem Vortrag hat er sogar erwähnt, dass quasi die ähm.
Alphabetisierung in Brei unter ähm Menschen mit eingeschränkten Sehvermögen zurückgeht.
Weil sie eben mit den Computern nix anfangen können und dann gar keine Veranlassung mehr haben. Äh jetzt breit zu lernen beziehungsweise dann über Voice Control vielleicht arbeiten oder so, ne? Und äh ja finde ich also,
Das fand ich echt mal cool um was Leute sich kümmern, welche Probleme die angehen,
und äh das Gerät sei natürlich auch noch ziemlich cool aus.
Ja, also da gibt's äh viel zu entdecken. Es gibt natürlich auch über den Batch und über Micropheisen gibt's äh Talks ähm,
Die Sachen, die ich jetzt gesehen habe, sind irgendwie fast alle nicht aufgezeichnet worden das war so ein bisschen blöd. Ähm aber ja, schaut rein, da ist auf jeden Fall was äh zu holen und.
In zwei Jahren gibt's wahrscheinlich wieder EMF,
Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das dieselbe Location bleiben wird, die war nämlich gut und die ist noch erweiterungsfähig.
Auch sehr gut zu erreichen, muss man sozusagen, also verkehrstechnisch äh echt gut gelegen, so direkt in Spuckweite der beiden großen Flughäfen, Heathrow und Gatwick,
Ja, so viel zu dem Camp dieses Jahr. Dann noch ein.
Zweiter Nachtrag und Ausblick. Ich war danach noch äh auf dem Rückweg mit dem Wohnwagen unterwegs gewesen, mich dann auch durch Holland gekommen und in Holland war dann am letzten Samstag.
Ein äh sogenannter Feel Day zum nächsten äh Camp sage ich jetzt mal, nicht Hickercamp.
Der holländischen Community, die auch mittlerweile glaube ich eh nicht gesehen werden kann, wie diese englische Community, also auch da baut sich sehr viel auf in den letzten fünf, sechs Jahren entstandenen Meckersbases auf.
Muss man auch sagen, die holländische Community hat die ganze Idee der Outdoor-Camps quasi erfunden, also dreiundneunzig mit Hacking at die End of the Universe und ähm.
Ähm der Hip.
Hacking in Prograss neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig. Das waren eigentlich so die beiden Veranstaltungen, die diese ganze Idee erst so richtig ins Rollen gebracht haben. Dann sind wir ja mit dem ersten Chaos Gummikirchencamp dann äh gefolgt neunundneunzig.
Ja und jetzt äh wird dann im nächsten Jahr mal wieder vier Jahre vorbei sein und äh ja in Holland ist so, äh Bus heißt ja immer alles CC, um's schön einfach zu machen
genauso verwirrend. Äh da wird dann jedes Mal ein neues Agrony ausgedacht. Also es ging los mit,
Heuhacking of Universe, dann kam Hiphaking, Progress, dann kam Hell, zweitausendeins, der passend, Hacking, Hackers at Lage, äh, what the hack,
Was äh gemeinhin auch für den Holländern nur noch als Wort The Rain.
Referiziert wird, weil da hat's halt viel geregnet. Äh dann kam Hacking and Random, dann kam oben, über eine Veranstaltung.
Ob Surf-Hackmake auch ein sehr schöner
Titel dazu hatten wir ja auch eine längere Auslassung über die Probleme, die es dort auch gab zwischen der deutschen und holländischen Community und einer Bewertung der Veranstaltung auch als solcher
mal gucken, wann das hier war, genau und ja ähm,
Nun wird es nächstes Jahr wieder soweit sein und einen Titel gibt's auch schon und zwar heißt die Veranstaltung Schar, also SHA zwanzig siebzehn. Äh man scheint sich noch nicht so ganz so sicher zu sein,
Was das heißt oder ob das überhaupt irgendwas heißen soll
von Shithappens Aniway bis Sam Hacker Agronum habe ich schon so verschiedene Übersetzungsversuche gefunden,
hier ist dann wahrscheinlich eher sagen wir mal das kryptische im Mittelpunkt, was ja dann ausgerechnet für die Abkürzung schar auch sehr passend ist, weil das ja nun,
Wie viele von euch natürlich wissen äh ein Algorithmus zum verheschen, also,
zum Reduzieren eines eine Information auf auf einen kurzen Zahlencode gedacht ist.
Das stimmt nicht. Die Information wird nicht reduziert. Ja doch, wird reduziert. Dies haben wir dann auch ordentlich weg.
Das ist nicht so falsch, dass du es äh jetzt angemessen hier finden kannst, dass du.
War auf jeden Fall auf diesem Day.
Und ja was kann man dazu sagen? Da sind irgendwie knapp hundert Leute zusammengekommen, das war ganz nett. Also wir haben quasi die Begehung des Geländes kombiniert mit so einer Art Mini,
Camp. Also man kam an, hat äh Tender
Tens ausgerollt und saß dann auch zusammen und hatte eine leicht kleine Vortrags äh Situation, das ging alles sehr rasant. Am Abend gab's irgendwie Barbecue, war alles äh sehr nice. Ja, da hat sich dann im Prinzip auch so diese ganze Euro-Community
das erste Mal neu gefunden und es wurden halt neue Volunteers äh mit in Gruppen mit reingenommen. Es wurde überhaupt mal so ein bisschen die das Gelände vorgestellt und die äh ja, Probleme und Herausforderungen, die es dort zu bewältigen gibt,
ähm deutlicher gemacht. Ja, ich muss sagen, ich habe so den Eindruck, dass das äh ganz gut werden wird,
das Gelände ist bemerkenswert, bemerkenswert groß, befindet sich wieder in Flevoland, wo schon zwei dieser holländischen Camps waren,
ist in dieser Insel, ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt denn eigentlich diese diese Inselkomplex? Also wo all die Stadt Almera auch drauf angelegt ist, das ist halt vor ja, weiß gar nicht, wie lange das her ist,
hundert, hunderte Jahre, weiß gar nicht, wie lange es das schon gibt.
Mal dem Meer abgerungen wurden und liegt halt auch unter dem Meeresspiegel, was ganz interessant ist, der Deich ist ein Spuckweite und man äh ist quasi auf so einem, ja, auf so einem Gebiet, was eben so ein, zwei Meter da drunter liegt.
Ähm ja von daher pack Gummistiefel ein,
Immer äh Gummistiefel und Autaren. Ähm ja, sehr viel mehr gibt's dazu jetzt noch nicht zu sagen. Hm, wer Lust hat, sich da mit noch als Freiwillige mit einzubringen
kann nachschlagen und da ist HA zwanzig siebzehn Punkt org. Da sind jetzt noch nicht so richtig viele,
Informationen, auch der Termin steht noch nicht wirklich fest, das ist glaube ich so in etwa die erste Augustwoche ins Auge gefasst worden, ob's das wird oder eine Woche später, das muss man dann nochmal sehen.
Ich habe den glaube ich schon öfter mal empfohlen, aber CAE einhundertzweiundsiebzig Holland und die Hacker.
Genau mit Robring.
Mit Rob. Da kann man noch über die ersten Camps.
Reden. Das war der Folge, die ich immer wieder in sehr schöner Erinnerung habe.
Genau, da habe ich mit Rob äh länger äh gesprochen über diese erste Zeit. Und das ganz interessant, weil da kriegt man einen Einblick, wie das alles gestartet ist. Damals gab's halt mit Hektik und äh Ob und dem erweiterten Freundeskreis gab's halt so eine kleinere Community, die
sehr dem Club sehr nahe stand und im Zuge des Generationswechsels, dem Unvermeidlichen
ist allerdings so diese Struktur nicht so fortgesetzt worden, also während der CC ja noch bis heute Bestand hat ist sozusagen die Organisation Hektik dann irgendwann einfach mal,
gefallen, ja auch ein Magazin rausgebracht et cetera und das ist halt jetzt eher ersetzt worden durch so eine neue Generation, die sich wie schon eingangs erwähnt, mehr über diese neuen Meckerspaces
definiert, die so im Zuge der H zweitausendneun
entstanden sind und ja also jetzt auch sagen wir mal anderes Eigenkulturverständnis haben.
Ja, trotz alledem, wenn das Leute dort getroffen und ich denke, es wird cool.
Ja, ja.
Na, damit kommen wir zum Ende der Sendung.
Kommen wir zum Ende der Sendung. Noch irgendwas loszuwerden.
Hier steht Epilog, was machen wir denn jetzt hier für einen Epilo.
Ja, Thema Drowe rumquatschen und versuchen irgendwie noch den einen oder anderen Witz äh zu bemühen oder so.
Also freut euch ein drittes Terrorpaket schaffen, Antiterrorpaket schaffen sie wahrscheinlich zweitausendsechzehn nicht. Das heißt so nach dem so es wird jetzt nochmal.
Schmerzhaft aber dann auch erst wieder nächstes Jahr.
Wie beruhigend.
Ja, ist doch schön, denn da können wir nochmal einen Kongress machen.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass da wahrscheinlich bald ein CFP geben wird.
Nein. Aber wir können bestätigen der drei der dreiunddreißig C drei wird A stattfinden B in Hamburg stattfinden am selben Ort
Weil das ist ja auch noch nicht so richtig kommuniziert äh und ja über mehr Dinge können wir noch keiner Auskunft geben, weil das weiß auch noch keiner, weil dieser Club ist irgendwie auch immer in so einer Sommerstarre mit all diesen ganzen Open Air
Events, um auf die man sich so konzentriert und erst wenn die Sonne äh nicht mehr so warm hier reinstrahlt, dann geht's.
Dann kommt irgendwann jemand und sagt, wir wollen da doch noch diesen CFP veröffentlichen. Linus, mach du das doch mal.
Wir wollten doch da irgendwie, was ist überhaupt? Was ist überhaupt? Was ist denn überhaupt mit dem Kongress.
Ja also es wird relativ relativ zeitnah wird der CFP veröffentlicht werden, dann könnt ihr bitte schön einreichen. Könnt ihr euch jetzt schon mal Gedanken machen.
Gut, das war's. Wir sagen tschüss.
Ja, einmal nochmal, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ich dem Benjamin gedankt habe, deswegen danke ich einfach zur Sicherheit nochmal.
Okay, gut. Haben wir das auch gemacht. Jetzt aber. Jetzt haben wir schon. Tschüss.
Jetzt aber, ciao ciao.